a lot of people were saying like oh this
whole idea of Game Theory it's just
nonsense and if you really want to make
money you got to like look into the
other person's eyes and read their soul
and figure out what cards they have but
what happened was where we played our
bot against four top heads up no limit
Hold'em poker players and the bot wasn't
trying to adapt to them it wasn't trying
to exploit them it wasn't trying to do
these Mind Games it was just trying to
approximate the Nash equilibrium and it
crushed them
the following is a conversation with no
Brown research scientists at Fair
Facebook AI research group at meta AI he
co-created the first AI system that
achieved superhuman level performance in
No Limit Texas Hold'em both heads up and
multiplayer and now recently he
co-created an AI system that can
strategically out-negotiate humans using
natural language in a popular board game
called diplomacy which is a war game
that emphasizes negotiation
this is a Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's gnome proud
you've been a lead on three amazing AI
projects so we've got libratus that
solved or at least achieved human level
performance on No Limit Texas Hold'em
poker with two players heads up
you got pluribus that solved No Limit
Texas HoldEm Poker with six players and
just now you have Cicero these are all
names of systems that solved or achieved
human level performance on the game of
diplomacy which for people who don't
know is a popular strategy board game it
was loved by JFK John F Kennedy and
Henry Kissinger and many other big
famous people in the decades since so
let's talk about poker and diplomacy
today first poker what is the game of No
Limit Texas Hold'em and how's it
different from chess well no limit Texas
hold 'em poker is the most popular
variant of Poker in the world
so you know you go to a casino you play
sit down at the poker table the game
that you're playing is no limit Texas
Hold'em
if you watch movies about poker like
Casino Royale or rounders the game that
they're playing is no limit Texas hold
in poker
now it's very different from limit
Hold'em in that you can bet any amount
of chips that you want and so the stakes
escalate really quickly you start out
with like one or two dollars in the pot
and then by the end of the hand you've
got like a thousand dollars in there
maybe so the option to increase the
number of very aggressively very quickly
is always there right the No Limit
aspect is there's no limit to how much
you can bet you know you in limit
Hold'em there's like two dollars in the
Pod you you can only bet like two
dollars but if you got ten thousand
dollars in front of you you're always
welcome to put ten thousand dollars into
the pot so I've got a chance to hang out
with uh Phil Hellmuth who plays all
these different variants of Poker and
correct me if I'm wrong but it seems
like no limit rewards crazy versus the
other ones rewards more kind of
calculated strategy or or no because
you're sort of looking from an from an
analytic perspective is is strategy also
rewarded in No Limit taxes hold on I
think both variance reward strategy but
I think what's different about No Limit
Hold'em is it's it's much easier to get
jumpy you know you go in there thinking
you're going to lose you're going to
play for like a hundred dollars or
something and suddenly there's like you
know a thousand dollars in the pot a lot
of people can't handle that can you
define jumpy when you're playing poker
you always want to choose the action
that's going to maximize your expected
value it's kind of like kind of like
with investing right like if you're ever
in a situation where you're the amount
of money that's at stake is
um is going to have a material impact on
your life then you're going to play in a
more risk-averse style you know if
somebody makes a huge bet you're gonna
if you're playing no limit hold them and
somebody makes a huge bet
there might come a point where you're
like this is too much money for me to
handle like I can't risk this amount uh
and that's what throws a lot of people
off
so that's the big difference I think
between No Limit and limit what about on
the action side when you're actually
making that big bet that's what I mean
by crazy I was I was trying to refer to
the technical the the technical term of
crazy meaning use the big jump in the
BET to completely throw off the other
person in terms of
um their ability to reason optimally I
think that's right I think
one of the key strategies in poker is to
put the other person into an
uncomfortable position and if you're
doing that then you're you're playing
poker well and there's a lot of
opportunities to do that in no limit
Hold'em you know you can have like 50 in
there you throw in a thousand dollar bet
and um you know that's sometimes if you
do it right it puts the other person in
a really tough spot now it's also
possible that you make huge mistakes
that way and so it's really easy to lose
a lot of money and no limit hold them if
you don't know what you're doing
um but there's a lot of upside potential
too so when you build systems AI systems
that play these games we'll talk about
poker we'll talk about diplomacy
are you um are you drawn in in part by
the beauty of the game itself AI aside
or is it to you primarily a fascinating
problem set for the eye to solve I'm
drawn in by the beauty of the game uh
when I I started playing poker when I
was in high school and the idea to me
that there is a correct and objectively
correct way of playing poker and if you
could figure out what that is then
you're you know you're making unlimited
money basically
that's like a really fascinating concept
to me
um and so I was fascinated by the
strategy of Poker even when I was like
16 years old it wasn't until like much
later that I actually worked on poker
AIS so there was a sense that you can
solve poker like uh in the way you can
solve chess for example or Checkers I
believe Checkers got solved right yeah
Checkers Checkers are completely solved
up optimal optimal strategy it's
impossible to beat the AI yeah and so in
that same way you could technically
solve chess
you could solve chess you could solve
poker you could solve poker so this is
this gets into the concept of an ash
equilibrium yeah so it is a Nash
equilibrium Okay so
and any finite two-player zero-sum game
there is an optimal strategy that if you
play it you are guaranteed to not lose
an expectation no matter what your
opponent does
and this is kind of a radical concept to
a lot of people
um but it's true in chess it's true in
poker it's true in any finite two-player
zero-sum game
and to give some intuition for this you
can think of rock paper scissors
and rock paper scissors if you randomly
choose between throwing rock paper and
scissors with equal probability then no
matter what your opponent does you are
not going to lose an expectation you're
not going to lose an expectation in the
long run
now the same is true for poker there
exists some strategy some really
complicated strategy that if you play
that you are guaranteed to not lose
money in the long run and I should say
this is for two player poker six player
poker is a different story yeah it's a
beautiful giant mess when you say in
expectation you're guaranteed not to
lose in expectation what does in
expectation mean Poker is a very high
variance game so you're gonna have hands
where you win you're gonna have hands
with your lose even if you're playing
the perfect strategy you can't guarantee
they're going to win every single hand
but if you play for long enough then you
are guaranteed to at least break even
and and practice probably one
so that's an expectation the size of
your stack generally speaking now that
doesn't include anything about the fact
that you can go broke it doesn't include
any of those kinds of normal real world
limitations you're talking you know in
the theoretical world
uh what about this the zero-sum aspect
how big of a constraint is that how big
of a constraint is finite
so
finite's not a huge constraint so I mean
most games that you play are finite in
size
um it's also true actually that there
exists this like perfect strategy in
many infinite games as well technically
the game has to be compact
um there are like some edge cases where
you don't have an ash equilibrium and a
two player zero-sum game so you can
think of a game where you like you know
if we're playing a game where whoever
names the bigger number is the winner
there's no Nash equilibrium to that game
17 yeah 18. but you beat you win again
you're good at this I played a lot of
games
okay uh so that's and then the Zero Sum
aspect the zero zero sum aspects so
there exists a Nash equilibrium in non
two player zero-sum games as well and by
the way just to clarify what I mean by
two player Zero Sum I mean there's two
players and whatever one player wins the
other player loses so if we're applying
poker and I win 50 that means that
you're losing fifty dollars
now outside of two player zero-sum games
there still exists Nash equilibria but
they're not as meaningful because you
know you can think of a game like Risk
if everybody else at the and on the
board decides a team up against you and
take you out there's no perfect strategy
you can play that's gonna guarantee that
you win there there's just nothing you
can do so outside of two players zero
some games there's no guarantee that
you're going to win by playing a
national equilibrium
have you ever tried to model in the
other aspects of the game
which is like the pleasure you draw from
playing the game and then if you're a
professional poker player if you're
exciting even if you lose
uh the you know the money you would get
from the attention you get to the
sponsor and all that kind of stuff is
that that would be a fun thing to model
to model in as I'd be make it sort of
super complex to include the human
factor in this in this full complexity I
think you bring up a couple good points
there so I think a lot of professional
poker players I mean they got a huge
amount of money not from actually
playing poker but from the sponsorships
and having a personality that people
want to tune in and watch that that's a
big that's a big way to to make a name
for yourself in poker I just wanted from
an AI perspective if you create and
we'll talk about this more maybe a AI
system that also talks trash and all
that kind of stuff that that becomes
part of the function to maximize so it's
not just optimal poker play maybe
sometimes you want to be chaotic maybe
sometimes you want to be suboptimal and
you lose
um the the chaos and maybe sometimes you
want to be overly aggressive because
people the audience loves that
that's fascinating I think I think what
you're getting at here is that there's a
difference between making an AI that
wins a game and an AI That's fun to play
with right yeah yeah and more fun to
watch so those are all different things
fun to play with and fun to watch yeah
and I think you know I've I've heard uh
talks from like game designers and and
they say like you know people that work
on AI for actual recreational games that
people play and they say yeah there's a
big difference between trying to make an
area that actually wins and you know you
look at a game like Civilization
um the way that the AIS play is not
optimal for trying to win they're
they're playing a different game they're
trying to have personalities they're
trying to be fun and engaging
um and that makes for a better game yeah
and we also talk about NPCs I just
talked to Todd Howard who is the the
creator of Fallout in the Elder Scrolls
series and
um Starfield the new game coming out and
the Creator what I think is the greatest
game of all time which is Skyrim and the
NPCs there the AI that governs that
whole game is very interesting but the
NPCs also are super interesting and
considering what language models might
do to NPCs in an open world RPG
role-playing game
it's super exciting yeah honestly I'm I
think this is like one of the first
applications where we're going to see
like real consumer interaction with
large language models
um I guess what sky um Elder Scrolls 6
is in development now they're probably
like pretty close to finishing it but I
would not be surprised at all if Elder
Scrolls 7 was using large language
models for their NPCs no they're not
they're I mean I'm not saying anything
not saying anything this is me
speculating not you no but but there's
they're just releasing the star feel
good they do one game at a time yeah and
so uh whatever it is whenever the date
is I don't know what the data is calm
down uh but it would be I don't know
like uh 20 24 25 26 so it's actually
very possible they would include
language models I was listening to this
um this talk by a gaming executive uh
when I was in grad school
and one of the questions that a person
in the audience asked is why are all
these games so focused on fighting and
killing and the person responded that
it's just so much harder to make an AI
that can talk with you and cooperate
with you than it is to make an AI that
can fight you
and I think once this technology
develops further and you can have a you
can reach a point where like not every
single line of dialogue has to be
scripted it unlocks a lot of potential
for new kinds of games like much more
like positive interactions that are not
so focused on fighting and I'm really
looking forward to that well it might
not be positive it might be just drama
you'll be in like a Call of Duty game
instead of doing the shooting you'll
just be hanging out and like arguing
with an AI about like
um like passive aggressive and then you
won't be able to sleep that night you
have to return or continue the argument
that you were uh emotionally hurt uh
I mean yeah I think that's actually an
exciting World whatever whatever is the
drama the chaos that we love the push
and pull of human connection I think
it's possible to do that in the video
game world and I think you could be
Messier and make more mistakes in the
Video Game World which is why it would
be a nice place and and also it doesn't
have a deep of a as deep of a real
psychological impact because inside
video games it's kind of understood that
you're in a not a real world so whatever
crazy stuff AI does we have some
flexibility to play just like with the
game of diplomacy it's a game this is
not real geopolitics not real war it's a
it's a game so you could you can have a
little bit of fun a little bit of chaos
okay back to Natural uh how do we find
the Nash equilibrium
all right so there's different ways to
find an ash equilibrium so um
the way that we do it is with this
process called self-play
um basically we have this algorithm that
starts by playing totally randomly and
it learns how to play the game by
playing against itself
so
um it will start playing the game
totally randomly and then it you know if
it's playing poker it'll eventually like
get to the end of the end of the game
and make fifty dollars
and then it will like review all the
decisions that it made along the way and
say what would have happened if I had
chosen this other action instead you
know if I had raised here instead of
called
um what would the other player have done
and because it's playing against a copy
of itself it's able to do that
counterfactual reasoning so they can say
okay well if I took this action and the
other person takes this action and then
I take this action and eventually I make
150 instead of 50.
and so it updates the regret value for
that action
regret is basically like how much does
it regret having not played that action
in the past
and when it encounters that same
situation again it's going to pick
actions that have higher regret with
higher probability
now
it'll just keep simulating the games
this way it'll keep um you know
accumulating regrets for different
situations
um and in the long run if you pick
actions that have higher regret with
higher probability in the correct way
it's proven to converge to a Nash
equilibrium
even for super complex games even for
imperfect information games it's true
for all games it's true for it's true
for chess it's true for poker it's
particularly useful for poker so this is
the the method of contractual regret
minimization this is counter factual
regret minimization that doesn't have to
do with self-play has to do with just
any any if you follow this kind of
process self-play or not you'll be able
to arrive in an optimal set of actions
so this counterfactual regret
minimization is a kind of self-play it's
a principled kind of self-play that's
proven to converge to Nash equilibria
even in in private information games now
you can have other forms of self-play
and people use other forms of self-play
for perfect information games
um where you have more flexibility the
algorithm doesn't have to be as
theoretically sound in order to converge
to that class of games because there's
uh it's a simpler setting sure so I kind
of in my brain the word self-play has
mapped in you all networks but we're
speaking something bigger than just
neural networks it could be anything
the self-play mechanism is just the
mechanism of a system playing itself
exactly yeah self-play is not tied
specifically to neural Nets it's it's a
kind of reinforcement learning basically
okay and I would also say this process
of like trying to reason oh what would
the value have been if I had taken this
other action instead this is very
similar to how humans learn to play a
game like poker right like you probably
played poker before and with your
friends you probably asked like oh what
do you have called me if I raised there
you know and that's that's a person
trying to do the same kind of like
learning from a counter factual that the
AI is doing okay and if you do that at
scale you're going to be able to learn
an optimal policy yeah now where the
neural nets come in I said like okay if
it's in that situation again then it
will choose the action that has high
regret now the problem is that poker is
such a huge game you know I think no
limit Texas Hold'em the version that we
were playing has 10 to the 161 different
decision points which is more than the
number of atoms in the universe squared
that's heads up that's heads up yeah 10
to the 161 you said yeah I mean it
depends on the number of chips that you
have the stacks and everything but like
the version that we were playing was
tense to the 161. which I assume would
be a somewhat simplified version anyway
because the about there's some like step
function you had for like bets oh no no
that's that's I'm saying like we played
the the full game you can bet whatever
amount you want another thought maybe
was constrained in like what it
considered for bed sizes but the the
person on the other side could bet
whatever they wanted yeah I mean 161
plus or minus 10 doesn't matter yeah
um and so the way neural Nets help out
here is you know you don't have to run
into the same exact situation because
that's never going to happen again the
odds of you running into the same exact
situation are pretty slim but if you run
into a similar situation then you can
generalize from other states that you've
been in that kind of look like that one
and you can say like well these other
situations I had high regret for this
action and so maybe I should play that
action here as well which is the more
complex game chess or poker or go or
poker do you know that is a
controversial question okay um I'm gonna
it's like somebody screaming on Reddit
right now it depends on which subreddit
you're on is it chess or is it poker I'm
sure like David Silver's gonna get
really angry at me yeah I'll say I'm
gonna say poker actually and I think for
a couple reasons
um they're not here to defend themselves
so first of all you have the imperfect
information aspect and so it's um it we
can go into that but like once you
introduce imperfect information uh
things get much more complicated so we
should say
maybe you can describe what is seen to
the players what is not seen uh in the
game of Texas Hold'em yeah so Texas
Hold'em you get two cards face down that
only you see
um and so that's the hidden information
of the game the other players also all
get two cards face down that only they
see
um and so you have to kind of as you're
playing reason about like okay what do
they think I have what do they have what
do they think I think they have that
kind of stuff and
um that's that's kind of where bluffing
comes into play right because the fact
that you can Bluff the fact that you can
bet with a bad hand and still win is
because they don't know what your cards
are right and that's the that's the key
difference between a perfect information
game like poker uh sorry like chess and
go
um and imprint information games like
poker this is what trash talk looks like
the implied statement is the game I
solved is much tougher uh but yeah so uh
when you're playing I'm just gonna do
random questions here so what when
you're playing your opponent
under imperfect information
is there some degree to which you're
trying to estimate the range of hands
that they have
or is that not part of the algorithm so
how what are the different approaches to
the imperfect information game so the
key thing to understand about why in
perfect information makes things
difficult is that you have to worry not
just about which actions to play but the
probability that you're going to play
those actions
so you think about
um rock paper scissors for example rock
paper scissors is an imperfect
information game
um right because you don't know what I'm
about to throw I do but yeah usually not
yeah yeah and so you can't just say like
I'm just gonna throw a rock every single
time because the other person is going
to figure that out and notice a pattern
and then suddenly you're going to start
losing and so you don't just have to
figure out like which action to play you
have to figure out the probability that
you play it and really importantly the
value of an action depends on the
probability that you're going to play it
so if you're playing Rock every single
time that value is really low but if
you're never playing rock you play Rock
like one percent of the time then
suddenly the the other person's probably
gonna be throwing scissors and when you
throw rock the value of that action is
going to be really high
now you take that to Poker what that
means is
the value of bluffing for example if
you're the kind of person that never
Bluffs and you have this reputation as
somebody that never Bluffs and suddenly
you Bluff there's a really good chance
that that bluff is going to work and
you're gonna make a lot of money on the
other hand if you've got a reputation
like if they seen you play for a long
time and they see oh you're the kind of
person that's bluffing all the time
when you Bluff they're not going to buy
it and they're going to call you down
you're going to lose a lot of money
and that finding that balance of how
often you should be bluffing is uh the
key challenge of a game of poker
and um you contrast that with a game
like chess
it doesn't matter if you're opening with
the Queen's Gambit 10 of the time or 100
of the time the value the expected value
is the same
so um so that's that's why we need these
algorithms that understand not just we
have to figure out what actions are good
but the probabilities we need to get the
exact probabilities correct and that's
actually when we created the bot
labradus libratus means balanced because
the algorithm that we designed was
designed to find that right balance of
how often it should play each action
the balance of how often in the key sort
of branching is the bluff or not the
bluff
is that a is that a good crude
simplification of the major decision in
poker it's a good simplification I think
that's like the main tension but it's
it's not just how often the bluff or not
to Bluff it's like how often should you
bet in general how often should you what
what kind of bet should you make
um should you bet big or should you bet
small and with which with which hands uh
and so this is where the idea of a range
comes from because when you are bluffing
with a particular hand in a particular
spot
you don't want there to be a pattern for
the other person to pick up on you don't
want them to figure out oh whenever this
person is in this spot they're always
bluffing and so you have to reason about
okay would I also bet with a good hand
in this spot
you want to be unpredictable so you have
to think about what would I do if I had
this different set of cards is there
explicit estimation of like a theory of
mind that the other person has about you
or is that just a emergent thing that
happens
the way that the Bots handle it that are
really successful they have an explicit
theory of mine so they're explicitly
reasoning about what are what's the
common knowledge belief what does what
do you think I have what do I think you
have what do you think I think you have
um it's explicitly reasoning about that
is there multiple U's there so
maybe that's jumping ahead to six
players but is there a stickiness to the
person to so it's an iterative game
you're playing the same person
there is there's a stickiness to that
right you're gathering information as
you play it's not every every
um every hand is in your hand is there
um a continuation in terms of estimating
what kind of player I'm facing here
that's a good question so
you could approach the game that way the
way that the Bots do it they don't and
the way that humans approach it also
expert human players the way they
approach it is to basically assume that
you know my strategy so
I'm going to try to pick a strategy
where even if I were to play it for 10
000 hands and you could figure out
exactly what it was you still wouldn't
be able to beat it basically what that
means is I'm trying to approximate the
Nash equilibrium I'm trying to be
perfectly balanced because if if I'm
playing the national equilibrium even if
you know what my strategy is like I said
I'm still unbeatable in expectation so
so that's what that's what the bot aims
for and that's actually what a lot of
expert poker players aim for as well to
start by playing the Nash equilibrium
and then maybe if they spot weaknesses
in the way you're playing then they can
deviate a little bit to take advantage
of that
they aim to be unbeatable in expectation
okay
so who's the greatest poker player of
all time and why is it Phil Hellmuth so
this is for Phil uh so he's known
um
at least in part for maybe playing
sub-optimally and he still wins a lot
it's a bit chaotic so maybe
can you speak from an AI perspective
about the genius of his Madness or The
Madness of his genius
so playing sub optimally playing
chaotically
um as a way to make it hard to pin down
about what your strategy is so okay the
thing that I should explain first of all
was like Nash equilibrium it doesn't
mean that it's predictable the whole
point of it is that you're trying to be
unpredictable now I think when somebody
like Phil Hellmuth might be really
successful is not in being unpredictable
but in being able to
um take advantage of the other player
and figure out where they're being
predictable
or guiding the other player into
thinking that you have certain
weaknesses and then and then
understanding how they're going to
change their behavior they're going to
deviate from a Nash equilibrium style of
play to try to take advantage of those
perceived weaknesses and then counter
exploit them so you kind of get into the
Mind Games there so you think about
these heads up poker as a dance between
two agents I guess are you playing the
cards are you playing the the player so
this this gets down to a big argument in
the poker community and the academic
Community for a long time there was this
debate of like what's called GTO Game
Theory optimal poker or exploitative
play
and um up until about like 2017 when we
did the broadest match I think actually
exploitative play had the advantage a
lot of people were saying like oh this
whole idea of Game Theory it's just
nonsense and if you really want to make
money you got to like look into the
other person's eyes and read their soul
and figure out what cards they have but
what happened was people started
adopting the game theory optimal
strategy
um and they were making good money and
they weren't trying to adapt so much to
the other player they were just trying
to play the national equilibrium and
then what really solidified it I think
was the broadest the broadest match
where we played our bot against four top
heads up no limit Hold'em poker players
and the bot wasn't trying to adapt to
them it wasn't trying to exploit them it
wasn't trying to do these Mind Games it
was just trying to approximate the Nash
equilibrium and it crushed them
I think you know
it we've we're playing for 50 100 blinds
and over the course of about 120 000
hands it made close to two million
dollars 120 000 hands 120 000 hands
against humans yeah and this was this
was fake money to be clear so there was
real money at stake there was 200 000
first of all all money is fake but um
that's that's that's a different
conversation
um we give it meaning uh it's an it's a
it's a phenomena that gets meaning from
our uh complex psychology as a human
civilization
um it's emerging from the collective
intelligence of the human species but
that's not what you mean you mean like
there's literally you can't you can't
buy stuff with it okay can you actually
uh step back and take me through that
um competition yeah okay so
when I was in grad school
um there was this thing called the
annual computer poker competition where
every year all the different research
Labs that were working on AI for poker
would get together they would make a bot
they would play them against each other
uh and we made a bot that actually won
the um 2014 competition the 2016
competition uh and so we decided we're
gonna take this bot build on it and play
against Real top professional heads up
no limit Texas hold 'em poker players
so we invited four of the world's best
players in this specialty and we
challenge them to 120 000 hands of poker
over the course of 20 days
um and we had 200 000 200 000 in prize
money at stake where it would basically
be divided among them depending on how
well they did relative to each other
so we wanted to have some incentive for
them to play their best
did you have a confidence
2014-16 that this is even possible how
much doubt was there so and we did a
competition actually in 2015 where we
also played against professional poker
players and the bot lost by by a pretty
sizable margin actually now there were
some big improvements from 2015 to 2017.
and so can you speak to the improvements
is it computational nature is it the
algorithm the the methods it was it was
really an algorithmic approach that was
the difference so 2015 it was much more
focused on trying to come up with a
strategy up front like trying to solve
the entire game of poker like and then
just have a lookup table where you're
saying like oh I'm in this situation
what's the strategy
um the approach that we took in 2017 was
much more search based it was trying to
say okay well let me in real time try to
compute a much better strategy than what
I had pre-computed by playing against
myself during self-play what is the
search space for
poker what are you searching over
what's that look like there's different
actions like raising calling yeah what
are the actions
um is it just a search over actions so
in a game like chess the the search is
like okay I'm in this chess position and
I can like you know move these different
pieces and see where things end up in
poker what you're searching over is the
actions you can take for your hand the
probabilities that you take those
actions and then also the probabilities
that you take other actions with other
hands that you might have
um and and that's kind of like a hard to
wrap your head around like why are you
searching over these like other hands
that you might have and like trying to
figure out what you would do with those
hands
um and the idea is is again you you
wanna
you wanna always be balanced and
unpredictable and so if you're a search
algorithm that's saying like oh I want
to raise with this hand well in order to
know whether that's a good action like
let's say it's a bluff you know let's
say you have a bad hand and you're
saying like oh I I think I should be
betting here with this really bad hand
and bluffing well that all that's only a
good action if you're also
betting with a strong hand otherwise
it's an obvious Bluff so if your action
in some sense maximizes your
unpredictability so that action could be
mapped by your opponent to a lot of
different hands then that's a good
action basically what you want to do is
put your opponent into a tough spot so
you want them to always have some doubt
like should I call here should I fold
here and if you are raising in the
appropriate balance between Bluffs and
good hands then you're putting them into
that tough spot and so that's what we're
trying to do we're always trying to
search for a strategy that would put the
opponent into a difficult position can
you give a metric that you're trying to
maximize or minimize does this have to
do with the regret thing what we're
talking about in terms of putting your
opponent in a maximally tough spot yeah
ultimately what you're trying to
maximize is your expected winnings like
your expected value the amount of money
that you're going to walk away from
assuming that your opponent was playing
optimally in response so you're going to
assume that your opponent is is also
playing um like as as well as possible
Nash equilibrium approach because if
they're not then you're just going to
make more money right like anything that
deviates like by definition the national
equilibrium is the strategy that does
the best in expectation and so if you're
deviating from that then you're just
they're going to lose money and since
it's a two player zero-sum game that
means you're gonna make money so there's
not an explicit like objective function
that maximizes the toughness of the spot
they're put in you're always
this is not from like a self-play
reinforcement learning perspective
you're just trying to maximize winnings
and the rest is implicit that's right
yeah so we're what we're actually trying
to maximize is the expected value given
that the opponent is playing optimally
in response to us now in practice what
that ends up looking like is it's
putting the opponent into difficult
situations where there's no obvious
decision to be made so the the system
doesn't know anything about the
difficulty of the situation not at all
it doesn't care okay yeah all right my
head was getting excited whenever I was
making the other the opponent's sweat
okay so you're in 2015 you didn't do as
well so what's the journey from that to
a system that in your mind could have a
chance so 2015 we we got we got beat
pretty badly and we actually learned a
lot from that competition and in
particular you know what became clear to
me is that the way the humans were
approaching the game was very different
from how the bot was approaching the
game the bot would not be doing search
it would just be trying to compute you
know it would do like months of
self-play it would just be playing
against itself for months but then when
it's actually playing the game it would
just act instantly
um and the humans when they're in a
tough spot they would sit there and
think for sometimes even like five
minutes about whether they're going to
call or fold a hand
um and it became clear to me that that's
there's a good chance that that's what
that's what's missing from our bot so I
actually did some
um initial experiments to try to figure
out how much of a difference this is
actually make and the difference was
huge as a signal to the human player how
long you took to think no no I'm not
saying that there were any timing tells
I was saying when the human like the bot
would always act instantly it wouldn't
try to come up with a better strategy in
real time
um over what it had precomputed during
training whereas the human like they
have all this intuition about how to
play but they're also in real time
leveraging their ability to think just
to search to plan
um and coming up with an even better
strategy than what their intuition would
say so you're saying that there's you're
doing that's what you mean by you're
doing search also you have an you have a
intuition and searched on top of that
looking for a better solution yeah
that's that's what I mean by search that
um instead of acting instantly you know
a neural net usually gives you a
response in like 100 milliseconds or
something it depends on the size of the
of the net but if you can leverage extra
computational resources
you can't possibly get a much better
outcome and we did some experiments in
small scale versions of Poker and what
we what we found was that if you
do a little bit of search even just a
little bit it was the equivalent of
making your you know your pre-computed
strategy like you could kind of think it
as your neural net a thousand times
bigger
with just a little bit of search and it
just like blew away all of the research
that we had been working on and trying
to like scale up this like pre-computed
solution it was dwarfed by the benefit
that we got from search
can you just Linger on what you mean by
search here you're searching over a
space of actions
for your hand and for other hands how
are you selecting the other hands to
search over
and so yeah randomly no it's all the
other hands that you could have so when
you're playing No Limit taxes hold on
you've got two face down cards and so
that's 52 choose two one thousand three
hundred twenty six different
combinations now that's actually a
little bit lower because there's
Facebook cards in the middle and so you
can eliminate those as well but you're
looking at like around a thousand
different possible hands that you can
have and so when we're doing when the
bot's doing search It's thinking
explicitly there are these thousand
different hands that I could have there
are these thousand different hands that
you could have
let me try to figure out what would it
be a better strategy than what I've
pre-computed for these hands and your
hands
Okay so
that search how do you fuse that with
what the neural net is telling you or
what the the the train system is telling
you yeah so
you kind of like where the train system
comes in is is the value
um at the end so there's
um you only look so far ahead you look
like maybe you know one round ahead so
if you're on the Flop you're looking to
the start of the turn
um
and at that point you can use the
pre-computed solution to figure out what
are what's the value here of like of
this strategy
is it of a single action essentially in
that spot you're getting a value or is
it the value of the entire series of
actions well it's kind of both
um because you're trying to maximize the
value for
the hand that you have but in the
process in order to maximize the value
of the hand that you have you have to
figure out what would I be doing with
all these other hands as well okay but
you are you in the search always going
to the end of the game in liberatis we
did uh so we only use search starting on
the turn and then we searched all the
way to the end of the game the turn the
river
uh can we take it through the
terminology yeah there's four rounds of
Poker so there's the pre-flop the Flop
the turn and the river uh and so we
would start doing search halfway through
the game now the first half of the game
that was all pre-computed it would just
act instantly and then when it got to at
the halfway point then it would always
search to the end of the game now we
later improved this so wouldn't have to
search all the way to the end of the
game it would actually search
um just a few moves ahead
um but that that came later and that
drastically reduced the num the amount
of computational resources that we
needed but the moves because you can
keep betting on top of each other that's
what you mean by moves so like that's
where you don't just get one bet
per Turner poker you can have multiple
arbitrary number of bets right right I'm
trying to think like I'm gonna bet and
then what are you gonna do in response
are you gonna raise me are you going to
call and then if you raise what should I
do so it's reasoning about that whole
process up until the end of the game in
the case of liberatis so for liberatis
what's the the most number of re-racists
have you ever seen
uh you probably cap out at like five or
something because at that point you're
basically all in you know I mean is
there like uh interesting patterns like
that that you've seen that the game does
like you you'll have like Alpha zero
doing way more sacrifices than humans
usually do is there something like the
bratis was constantly re-raising or
something like that even noticed there
was there was something really
interesting that we observed with the
broadest
um
so
humans when they're playing poker they
usually size their bets relative to the
size of the pot so you know if the pot
has a hundred dollars in there maybe you
bet like 75 or somewhere around there
somewhere between like 50 and 100
um and with libratus we gave it the
option to basically bet whatever it
wanted it was actually really easy for
us to say like oh if you want you can
bet like 10 times the pot and we didn't
think it would actually do that it was
just like why not give it the option and
then during the competition it actually
started doing this and by the way this
is like a very last minute decision on
our part to add this option and so we
did not we did not think the bot would
would do this and uh I was actually kind
of worried when it did start to do this
like oh is this is a problem like humans
don't do this like is it screwing up
um but it would put the humans into
really difficult spots when it would do
that
because you know you can imagine like
you have the second best hand that's
possible given the board and you're
thinking like oh you're in a really
great spot here and suddenly the bot
bets twenty thousand dollars into a you
know a thousand dollar pot and and it's
basically saying like I have the best
hand or I'm bluffing and you having the
second best hand like now you get a
really tough choice to make and so the
humans would sometimes think like five
or ten minutes about like what do you do
should I call should I fold and um and
when I saw the humans like really
struggling with that decision like
that's when I realized like oh actually
this is maybe a good thing to do after
all and of course the system doesn't
know that it's making again like we said
that it's putting them in a tough spot
it's it's it's just that's part of the
optimal the game theory optimal right
from the Bots perspective it's just it's
just doing the thing that's going to
make it the most money
um and the fact that it's putting the
humans in a difficult spot like that's
just um you know a side effect of that
and this was I think the the one thing I
mean there were a few things that the
humans walked away from but this was the
the number one thing that the humans
walked away from the competition saying
like we need to start doing this
um and now these over bats what are
called over bets have become really
common in high level poker play have you
ever talked to like somebody like Danny
on the ground about this he seems to be
a student of the game I did actually
have a conversation with Daniel degrania
once yeah I was uh I was visiting the
Isle of Man to talk to Poker Stars about
AI
um and Daniel legrandi was there when we
had dinner together with uh some other
people and um yeah he was really
interested in it he mentioned that he
was like you know excited about like
learning from these AIS
um so he wasn't scared he was excited he
was excited and uh and he all he
honestly he wanted to play against the
bot he thought he thought he had a
decent chance of beating it
um I I think he's you know
this was like several years ago and I
think it was like not as clear to
everybody that you know the AIS were
taking over I think now people recognize
that like if you're playing against uh a
bot there's like no chance that you have
in a game like Pokemon so consistently
the Bots will win the Bots have heads up
and in in other variants too so multi
multi six player Texas Hold'em No Limit
taxes hold them as the Bots win yeah
that's the case so I think there's some
debate about like is it true for every
single variant of Poker I think I think
for every single variant of Poker if
somebody really put in the effort they
can make an AI that would beat all
humans at it
um we've focused on the most popular
variants so heads up no limit Texas
Hold'em and then we followed it up with
um with uh six player poker as well
where we managed to uh make a bot that
beat expert human players and I think
even there now uh it's pretty clear that
humans don't stand a chance see I would
love to hook up an AI system that looks
at EEG
like how like actually tries to optimize
the toughness of the spot it puts a
human in and I I would I would love to
see how different is that from the game
theory optimal so you try to maximize
the heart rate of the human player like
the freaking out over a long period of
time I wonder if there's going to be
different strategies that emerge uh that
are close in terms of Effectiveness
because something tells me you could
still be
um achieved superhuman level performance
by just making people sweat
I feel like that there's a good chance
that that is the case yeah if you're
able to see like that it's like it's
like a decent proxy for score right
right um and this is actually like the
the common poker wisdom when they're
telling where they're teaching players
before the robots and they were trying
to teach people how to play poker they
would say like the key to the game is to
put your opponent into difficult spots
it's a good um a good estimate for if
you're making the right decision so what
else can you say about the fundamental
role of search in poker and maybe if you
can also relate it to chess and go in
these games
um
what's the role of search to solve in
these games
yeah I think a lot of people under this
is true for the general public and I
think it's true for the AI Community a
lot of people underestimate the
importance of search for these kinds of
game AI results
um an example of this is uh TD Gammon
that came out in 1992 this was the the
first real instance of a neural net
being used in a game AI it's a landmark
achievement it was actually the
inspiration for Alpha zero and it used
search it used two-ply search to figure
out its next move
you got deep blue there he was very
heavily focused on search
um looking many many moves ahead farther
than any human could and that was key
for why it won and then even with
something like alphago I mean alphago is
commonly hailed as a landmark
achievement for neural Nets and it is
but there's also this huge component of
search Monte Carlo tree search to
alphago that was key absolutely
essential for the AI to be able to beat
top humans
um I think a good example of this is you
look at the latest versions of alpha of
alphago like it was called Alpha zero
um and there's this metric called ELO
rating where you can compare different
humans and you can compare Bots to
humans now a top human player is around
3600 ELO maybe a little bit higher now
um Alpha zero the strongest version is
around 5200 ELO
but if you take out the search that's
being done at test time and by the way
what I mean by search is the planning
ahead the thinking of like oh if I move
my if I place the stone here and then he
does this and then you look like five
moves ahead and you see like what the
board state looks like
um that's what I mean by search if you
take out the search that's done during
the game the ELO rating drops to around
three thousand
so even today
what seven years after alphago
if you take out the Monte Carlo research
that's being done at one playing against
the human
the Bots are not superhuman nobody has
made a raw neural net that is superhuman
and go
that's worth lingering on that's that's
quite profound
so without search that just means
looking at the next move
and saying this is the best move so
having a function that estimates
accurately what the best move is that's
right without search yeah and all these
Bots they have the what's called a
policy Network where it will tell you
this is what the neural net thinks is
the next best move
um
and it's kind of like a the intuition
that a human has you know the human
looks at the board and and any uh go or
chess master will be able to tell you
like oh instantly here's what I think
the right move is
um and the bot is able to do the same
thing but just like how a human
Grandmaster can make a better decision
if they have more time to think when you
add on this Monte Carlo tree search the
bot is able to make a better decision
yeah I mean of course a human is doing
something like searching their brain but
it's not
I hesitate to draw a hard line but it's
not like uh Monte Carlo tree search it's
more like
sequential language model generation so
it's like a different it's a the neural
network is doing the searching and I
wonder what the human brain is doing in
terms of searching because you're doing
that like computation the human is
Computing they have intuition they've
got
they have a really strong ability to
estimate you know amongst the top
players of what is a good and not
position without calculating all the
details
but they're still doing search in their
head but it's a different kind of search
have you ever thought about like what is
the difference between the human
the search that the human is performing
versus what
computers are doing I have thought a lot
about that and I think it's a really
important question so the AI in Alpha
and Alphas in alphago or any of these go
AIS they're all doing Monte College
research which is a particular kind of
search and it it's actually a symbolic
tabular search it uses the neural net to
guide its search but it isn't actually
like full full-on neural net
now that kind of search is very
successful in these kinds of like
perfect information board games like
chess and go but if you take it to a
game like poker for example it doesn't
work it can't it can't understand the
concept of hidden information it doesn't
understand the balance that you have to
strike between like the amount that
you're raising versus the amount that
you're calling and in every one of these
games you see a different kind of search
and the human brain is able to plan for
all these different games in a very
general way now I think that's one thing
that we're missing from AI today and I
think it's a really important missing
piece the ability to plan and reason
more generally across a wide variety of
different settings
in a way where the general reasoning
makes you better at each one of the
games not worse yeah so you can kind of
think of it as like neural Nets today
they'll give you like Transformers for
example or super General but you know
they'll give you it'll output an answer
in like 100 milliseconds and if you tell
it like oh you've got five minutes to
give you a decision you know feel free
to take more time to make a better
decision it's not gonna know what to do
with that
um but a human if you're playing a game
like chess they're going to give you a
very different answer depending on if
you say oh you've got 100 milliseconds
or you've got five minutes
yeah there I mean that people have
started using right Transformers the
language models like the in an iterative
way that does improve the answer or like
showing the work the kind of kind of
idea yeah they got this thing called
Chain of Thought reasoning and that's I
think um super promising right yeah I
think and I think it's a good step in
the right direction
um I I would kind of like say it's
similar to Monte Carlo rollouts in in a
game like chess there's a kind of search
that you can do where you're saying like
I'm Gonna Roll Out My intuition and see
like without really thinking you know
what are the better decisions I can make
farther down the path
um what would I do if I just acted
according to intuition for the next 10
moves
um and that gets you an improvement but
I think that there's much uh much richer
kinds of of planning that we could do
so when the broadest actually beat the
poker plays what did I feel like what
was that I mean actually on that day
what were you feeling like were you were
you nervous
I mean Poco was one of the games that he
thought like is not going to be solvable
because it's the human factor so at
least in the narratives we tell
ourselves the human factor so
fundamental to the game of poker
yeah the liberatis competition was super
stressful for me
um also I mean I was working on this
like basically continuously for a year
leading up to the competition I mean for
me it became like very clear like okay
this is the search technique this is the
approach that we need and then I spent a
year working on this pretty much like
non-stop oh can we actually get into
details like what programming language
is it written in what's some interesting
uh implementation details that are like
fun slash painful yeah so one of the
interesting things about liberatis is
that we had no idea what the bar was to
actually beat top humans yeah we could
play against like our prior Bots and
that kind of gives us some sense of like
are we making progress are we going in
the right direction uh but we had no
idea like what the bar actually was and
so we threw a huge amount of resources
at trying to make the strongest bot
possible so we use C plus plus it was
parallelized we were using I think like
a thousand CPUs uh maybe maybe more
actually
um and you know today that sounds like
nothing but for a grad student back in
2016 that was a huge amount of resources
but still a lot for even any gratitude
today it's still tough to to get
or even to allow yourself to think in
that in terms of scale at CMU at MIT
anything like that yeah and you know
talking about terabytes of memory
um so it's a very paralyzed
um and it had to be very fast too
because the more games that you could
simulate uh the stronger the bot would
be so is there some like John Carmack
Style
like efficiencies you have to come up
with like an efficient way to represent
a hand all that kind of stuff there were
all sorts of optimizations that I had to
make to try to get this thing to run as
fast as possible they were like how do
you minimize the latency how do you like
you know package things together so that
like you minimize the amount of
communication between the different
nodes
um how do you like optimize the
algorithm so that you can you know try
to squeeze out more and more from the
game that you're actually playing all
these kinds of different decisions that
that I you know had to make uh just a
fun question what what id did you use
what uh for for C plus plus
I think I used a visual studio actually
yeah okay yeah is that still carried
through to today vs code is is what I
use today it seems like it's pretty the
community basically converged on Okay
cool so you got you got this
super optimized C plus plus system
and then you show up to the day of
competition
yeah
humans versus machine
um how did it feel throughout the day
super stressful
um I mean I thought going into it that
we had like a 50 50 chance because
basically I thought if if they play in a
totally normal style I think we'll
squeak out a win but there's always a
chance that they can find some weakness
in the bot and if they do and we're
playing like for 20 days 120 000 hands
of poker they have a lot of time to find
weaknesses in the system and if they do
we're gonna get crushed and that's
actually what happened in the previous
competition
um the humans you know they started out
it wasn't like a they were winning from
the start but then they found these
weaknesses that they could take
advantage of and for the next they know
like 10 days they were just just
crushing the bot stealing money from it
what were the weaknesses they found like
maybe over betting was effective that
kind of stuff so certain betting
strategies worked what they found is
yeah over betting like betting certain
amounts the bot would have a lot of
trouble dealing with those sizes and
then also
um when it the bot got into really
difficult all-in situations it wasn't
able to because it wasn't doing search
it had to Clump different hands together
and it wouldn't it would treat them
identically yeah um and so it wouldn't
be able to distinguish you know like
having a king High flush versus an ace
high flush and in some situations that
really matters a lot and so they could
put the bot into those situations and
then the bot would would just bleed
money clever humans yeah okay so I
didn't realize it was over 20 days so
um
what were the humans like over those 20
days and what was the bot like so we had
set up the competition you know like I
said there was two hundred thousand
dollars in prize money and they would
get paid a fraction of that depending on
how well they did relative to each other
yeah so I was kind of hoping that they
wouldn't work together to try to find
weaknesses in the bot but they entered
the competition with their like number
one objective being to beat the bot and
they didn't care about like individual
Glory they were like we're all going to
work as a team to try to take down the
spot yeah and so they immediately
started comparing notes what they would
do is they would coordinate looking at
different parts of the strategy to try
to try to you know find out weaknesses
um and then at the end of the day we
actually sent them a log of all the
hands that were played and what cards
the bot had on each of those hands oh
wow yeah that's that's gutsy yeah it was
honestly and I'm not sure why we did
that in retrospect but um I mean I'm
glad we did it because we ended up
winning anyway but that if if you've
ever played poker before like that is
golden information I mean to know
usually when you play poker you see
about a third of the hands to Showdown
um and to just hand them all the cards
that the bot had on every single hand
that was
um just just a gold mine for them yeah
and so then they would review the hands
and try to see like okay could they find
patterns in the bot the weaknesses and
could they then then they would
coordinate and study together and try to
figure out okay now this person's gonna
explore this part of the strategy for
weaknesses this person's gonna explore
this part of the strategy for weaknesses
it's a kind of psychological warfare
showing in the hands yeah
um I mean I'm sure you didn't think of
it that way but like doing that means
you're confident in the possibility to
win well that's that's one way of
putting it I wasn't uh super confident
yeah so
you know going in like I said I think I
had like 50 50 odds on us winning the
when we actually when we announced the
competition the poker Community decided
to gamble on who would win and their
initial odds against us were like four
to one they were really convinced that
the humans were gonna
pull out a win
um the bot ended up winning for three
days straight and even then after three
days the betting odds were still just 50
50.
um
and then at that point it started to
look like the humans were coming back
um they started to like you know but but
poker is a very high variance game
um and I think what happened is like
they thought that they spotted some
weaknesses that weren't actually there
and then around day eight it was just
very clear that they were getting
absolutely crushed
um and and from that point I mean for
for a while there I was super stressed
out thinking like oh my God the humans
are coming back and we're just they've
found weaknesses and now we're just
gonna lose the whole thing but no it
ended up going in the other direction
and the bot ended up like crushing them
in the long run
how did it uh feel at the end like as a
human being what it as a person who
loves appreciates the beauty of the Game
of Poker and the person who appreciates
the beauty of AI is there did you feel a
certain kind of way about it
uh I felt a lot of a lot of things man
um I mean at that point in my life I had
spent five years working on this project
and um it was a huge sense of
accomplishment I mean to spend five
years working on something and finally
see it succeed
um yeah I wouldn't trade that for
anything in the world yeah because it's
uh that's a real Benchmark it's not like
uh getting us some percent accuracy and
a data set this is like real this is
real world it's it's just a game but
it's also a game it means a lot to a lot
of people and this is humans doing their
best to beat the machine so this is a
real Benchmark unlike anything else yeah
and I mean this is this is what I have
been dreaming about since I was like 16
playing poker you know with my friends
in high school the idea that you could
find a strategy
um you know approximate the national
equilibrium be able to beat all the
poker players in the world with it you
know so to actually see that come to
fruition and be realized uh that was
is kind of magical
yeah especially money is on the line too
it's a different it's different than
chess
and that aspect like people get that's
why you want to look at Betty Marcus if
you want to actually understand what
people really think in the same sense
poker it's really high stakes because
it's money and to solve that game that's
that's an amazing accomplishment so the
leap from that to
multi-way six player poker what's how
difficult does that jump
and what are some interesting
differences between heads up poker and
and multi-way poker yeah so I mentioned
you know Nash equilibrium and two player
zero-sum games
if you play that strategy you are
guaranteed to not lose an expectation no
matter what your opponent does now once
you go to six player poker you're no
longer playing a two player zero-sum
game and so there was a lot of debate
among the academic community and among
the poker Community about how well these
techniques would extend beyond just
two-player heads-up poker now
what I have come to realize is that
um the techniques actually I thought
really would extend to six player poker
because even though in theory they don't
give you these guarantees outside of two
player zero some games in practice it
still gives you a really strong strategy
now there were a lot of complications
that would come up with six player poker
besides like the game theoretic aspect I
mean for one the game is Just
exponentially larger
um so the main thing that allowed us to
go from two player to six player was the
idea of depth limited search
so I said before like you know we would
do search we would plan out the bot
would plan out like what what it's going
to do next and for the next several
moves and in liberatis that search was
done extending all the way to the end of
the game so it would have to start
um it from from the turn onwards like
looking maybe 10 moves ahead
um it would have to figure out what it
was doing for all those moves
now when you get to six player poker it
can't do that exhaustive search anymore
because the game is just way too large
um but by only having to look a few
moves ahead and then stopping there and
substituting a Value Estimate of like
how good is that strategy at that point
then we're able to do a much more
scalable form of search
is there something cool looking at the
paper right now is there something cool
in the paper in terms of Graphics a game
tree Traverse of via Monte Carlo I think
if you go down a bit uh
uh figure one an example of equilibrium
selection problem ooh so yeah uh what do
we know about equilibria one is there's
multiple players so when you go outside
of two players you're a sum so a Nash
equilibrium is a set of strategies like
one strategy for each player where no
player has an incentive to switch to a
different strategy
um and so you can kind of think of it as
like imagine you have a game where
there's a ring that's actually the
visual here you got a ring and the
object of the game is to be as far away
from the other players as possible
there's an ash equilibrium is for all
the players to be spaced equally apart
around this ring
but there's infinitely many different
Nash equilibria right there's infinitely
many ways to space four dots along a
ring
And if every single player independently
computes a Nash equilibrium
then there's no guarantee that the joint
strategy that they're all playing is
going to result is going to be in Ash
equilibrium there they're just going to
be like random dots scattered along this
ring rather than four coordinated dots
being equally spaced apart is it
possible to sort of optimally do this
kind of selection
to do the selection about
um of the equilibrium you're chasing so
is there like a meta problem to be
solved here so the meta problem is in
some sense
um how do you how do you understand the
national equilibria that the other
players are going to play
um and and even if you do that again
there's no guarantee that you're going
to win so
you know if you're playing
uh if you're playing risk like I said
and and all the other players decide to
team up against you You're Gonna Lose
Nash equilibrium doesn't help you there
and so there was this big debate about
whether Nash equilibrium and all these
techniques that compute it are even
useful once you go outside of two player
zero some games now I think for many
games there is a valid criticism here
and I think when we talk about when we
go to something like diplomacy we run
into this issue that the approach of
trying to approximate a Nash equilibrium
doesn't really work anymore but it turns
out that in six player poker
um because six player poker is such an
adversarial game
um where none of the players really try
to work with each other
the techniques that were used in
two-player poker to try to approximate
an equilibrium those still end up
working in practice in in six player
poker there's some
deep way in which six player poker is
just a bunch of heads up poker like
games in one it's like uh it's like
embedded in it so the competitiveness
um is more fundamental to Poker than the
cooperation right yeah poker is just
such an adversarial game there's no real
cooperation in fact you're not even
allowed to cooperate in poker it's
considered collusion it's against the
rules
um
and so for that reason the techniques
end up working really well and I think
that's true more more broadly in
extremely adverse serial games in
general but that's sort of in practice
versus being able to prove something
that's right nobody has a proof that
that's the case and it could be that
that six player poker belongs to some
class of games where a pro approximating
an Azure equilibrium through self-play
provably works well
um and you know there are other classes
of games Beyond just two player Zero Sum
where this is proven to work well so
there are these you know kinds of games
called potential games which I won't go
into it's kind of like a complicated
concept but
um there are classes of games where uh
this approach to approximating an ash
equilibrium is proven to work well now
six player poker is not known to belong
to one of those classes but it is
possible that there is some classic
games where it either provably performs
well or provably performs not that badly
so what are some interesting things
about uh pluribus that was able to
achieve human level performance on this
or superhuman level performance on the
six player version of Poker I personally
I think the most interesting interesting
thing about pluribus is that it was so
much cheaper than libratus I mean
libratus if you had to put a price tag
on on the computational resources that
went into it I would say the final
training run took about a hundred
thousand dollars
you go to pluribus the final training
run would cost like less than 150 on AWS
is this normalized to computational
inflation so meaning uh this is is this
just does this just have to do with the
fact that pluribus was trained like a
year later
no no it's not it's I mean first of all
like yeah Computing resources are are
getting cheaper every day and like but
you're not going to see a thousand-fold
decrease in the computational resources
over two years
um or even anywhere close to that the
the real Improvement was algorithmic
improvements and in particular the
ability to do depth limited search
so it does depth limited search also
work for libratus yeah yes so where this
deploymented search came from is you
know I I developed this technique and
um ran it on two-player poker first and
that reduced the computational resources
needed to make an AI that was superhuman
from you know a hundred thousand dollars
for the broadest to something you could
train on your laptop what do you learn
from that
um from that discovery
what I would take away from that is that
algorithmic improvements really do
matter how would you describe the more
General case of limited Dev search
so it's basically constraining the scale
a temporal or in some other way of the
computation you're doing in some clever
way
so like with like how else can you
significantly constrain computation
right
well I think the idea is that we want to
be able to leverage search as much as
possible and the way that we were doing
it in liberatis required us to search
all the way to the end of the game now
if you're playing a game like chess the
idea that you're going to search always
to the end of the game is kind of
unimaginable right like there's just so
many situations where you just won't be
able to use search in that case or the
cost would be
um you know prohibitive
and this technique allowed us to
leverage search and without having to
pay such a huge computational cost for
it and be able to apply it more broadly
so to what degree did you use neural
nets for uh libratus and pluribus and
more generally what role do neural Nets
have to play
in um in super human level performance
in poker so we actually did not use
neural Nets at all for libratus or
pluribus and a lot of people found this
surprising back in 2017 I think they
found it surprising today
um that we were able to do this without
using any neural Nets um
and I think the reason for that I mean I
think neural Nets are
um incredibly powerful and the
techniques that are used today even for
poker AIS do rely uh quite heavily on
neural Nets
um but it wasn't the main challenge for
poker like I think what neural Nets are
really good for if you're in a situation
where finding features for a value
function is really difficult then neural
Nets are really powerful and this was
the problem in go right like the problem
and go
was that or the final problem in go at
least was that nobody had a good way of
looking at a board and figuring out who
was winning or describing
um through a simple algorithm who was
winning or losing
and so there neural Nets were super
helpful because you could just feed in a
ton of different board positions into
this neural net and it would be able to
predict then who was winning or losing
but in poker the features weren't the
challenge the the challenge was how do
you design a scalable algorithm that
would allow you to find this balance
strategy that would understand that you
have to Bluff with the right probability
so can that be somehow incorporated into
the value function this
the complexity of polka that you've
described yeah so the way the value
functions work in like the latest and
greatest poker AIS they do use neural
nets for the value function the way it's
done is is very different from how it's
done in a game like chess or go because
in poker you have to reason about
beliefs and so the value of a state
depends on the beliefs that players have
about what the different cards are like
if you have pocket aces then whether
that's a really really good hand or just
an okay hand depends on whether you know
I have pocket aces where like if you
know that I have pocket aces then if I
bet you're going to fold immediately but
if you think that I have a really bad
hand then I could bet with pocket aces
and make a ton of money so
the value function in poker these days
takes the beliefs as an input which is
very different from like how how chess
and go AIS work
so as a person who appreciates the game
uh
who do you think is the greatest poker
player of all time
that's a that's a tough question
um Can an AI help answer that question
can you can actually add analyze the
quality of play right so the AHS engines
can
can give estimates of the quality of
play right
um
I wonder if there's a is there an ELO
rating type of system for poker
I suppose you could but there's just not
enough
you would have to play a lot of games
right a very large number of games like
more than you would in chess the
deterministic game makes it easier to
estimate yellow
I think I think it is much harder to
estimate something like ELO rating in
poker I think it's doable the problem is
that the game is very high variants so
you could play you could be profitable
in poker for a year and you could
actually be a bad player just because
the variance is so high I mean you've
got top professional poker players that
would lose for a year just because
they're on a really bad
um bad streak so yeah so for ELO you
have to have a nice clean way of saying
if player a played player B
and a B's B that says something that's a
signal in poker it's a very noisy signal
it's a very noisy signal now there is a
signal there and so you could do this
this calculation it would just be much
harder
um but the same way that AIS have now
taken over chess and you know all the
top professional chess players train
with with AIS the same is true for poker
the game has become a very computational
um people trained with AIS to try to
find out where they're making mistakes
try to learn from the AIS to improve
their strategy so
now yeah so the game has been
revolutionized in the past five years by
by the development of AI in this sport
the skill with which you avoided the
question of the greatest of all time was
impressive so my feeling is that it's a
difficult it's a difficult question
because just like in chess where you
can't really compare Magnus Carlson
today to Gary Kasparov
um because the game has evolved so much
um the poker players today are so far
beyond the the skills of like people
that were playing even 10 or 20 years
ago
um so you look at the kinds of like
All-Stars that were on ESPN at like the
height of the poker boom
pretty much all those players are
actually not that good at the game today
at least at least the the strategy
aspect I mean there might be still be
good at like reading the player at the
other side of the table and trying to
figure out like are they bluffing or not
but in terms of the actual like
computational strategy of the game
um a lot of them have really struggled
to keep up with that development now
so for that reason I'll give an answer
and I'm gonna say Daniel negranio who
you actually had on the podcast recently
I saw was a great episode and I love
this so much and Phil's gonna hate this
so much and I'm gonna give him I'm gonna
give him credit because he is one of the
few like old school really strong
players that have kept up with the
development of AI so he is trying to
he's constantly studying the the game
theory optimal way of playing exactly
yeah and I think a lot of a lot of the
old school poker players are just kind
of given up on that aspect and and I got
to give them the ground you credit for
for keeping up with all the developments
that are happening in the sport yeah
it's fascinating to watch it's
fascinating to watch where it's headed
um yeah so there you go some love for
Daniel
quick pause bathroom break yeah let's do
it
let's go from poker to diplomacy
what is at a high level the game of
diplomacy
yeah so I talked a lot about two player
zero some games and what's interesting
about diplomacy is that it's very
different from these like adversarial uh
games like chess go poker even Starcraft
and DOTA diplomacy has a much bigger
Cooperative element to it it's a seven
player game it was actually created in
the 50s
um and it takes place
uh before World War one it's like a map
of Europe with seven Great Powers
um and they're all trying to form
alliances with each other there's a lot
of negotiation going on
um and so the whole focus of the game is
on
forming alliances with the other players
to take on the other players England
Germany Russia turkey Austria Hungary
Italy and France that's right yeah
so the way the game works is
on each turn you spend about you know
five to fifteen minutes talking to the
other players in privates and you make
all sorts of deals with them you say
like hey let's work together
um you know let's team up against this
other player because the only way that
you can make progress is by working with
somebody else against the others
um and then after that negotiation
period is done all the players
simultaneously submit their moves and
they're all executed at the same time
and so you can tell people like hey I'm
going to support you this turn
um but then you don't follow through
with it and they're only going to figure
that out once they see the moves being
read off how much of it is natural
language like written actual text how
much is like uh you're actually saying
phrases that are structured so there's
different ways to play the game you know
you can play it in person and in that
case it's all natural language freeform
communication there's no constraints on
the kinds of deals that you can make the
kinds of things that you can discuss
um it can also play it online so you can
you know send along emails back and
forth you can play it like live online
or over voice chat but the the focus the
important thing to understand is that
this is unstructured communication you
can say whatever you want
um you can make any sorts of deals that
you want and everything is done
privately so it's not like you're all
around the board together having a
conversation you're grabbing somebody
going off into a corner and conspiring
behind everybody else's back about what
you're planning and uh there's no limit
in theory to the conversation you can
have directly with one person that's
right you can make all sorts of you can
talk about anything you could say like
hey let's have a long-term alliance
against this guy you can say like hey
can you support me this turn and in
return I'll do this other thing for you
next turn or um you know yeah just you
can talk about like what you talked
about with somebody else and gossip
about like what they're planning
um the way that I would describe the
game is that it's kind of like a mix
between risk poker and the TV show
Survivor there's like this big element
of like trying to
um yeah there's a big social element and
the best way that I would describe the
game is that it's really a game about
people rather than the pieces
so risk because it is a map it's kind of
war game like
uh poker because there's a game theory
component that's very kind of strategic
so you could convert it into an
artificial intelligence problem and then
survive it because of the social
component that's a strong social
component I saw that somebody said
online that the internet version of the
game has this quality of that is easier
to almost to do like role playing
as opposed to being yourself you can
actually like be the like really imagine
yourself as the leader of France or
Russia and so on like really pretend to
be that person it's actually fun to
really lean into being that that leader
yeah so some some players do go this
route where they just like kind of view
it as a strategy game but also a
role-playing game where they can like
act out like what would I be like if I
was you know a leader of France in 1900
a forfeit right away no I'm just kidding
um
and they sometimes use like the
old-timey language to like
um or how they imagine the elites would
talk at that time anyway so the what are
the different turns of the game like
what are the rounds yeah so on on every
turn you got like a bunch of different
units that you start out with so you
start out um controlling like just a few
units and the object of the game is to
gain control of a majority of the map if
you able if you're able to do that then
you've won the game but like I said the
only way that you're able to do that is
by working with other players so on
every turn you can issue a move order so
for each of your units you can move them
to an adjacent territory
or you can keep them where they are or
you can support a move or a hold of a
different units so what are the
territories how how is the map divided
up it's kind of like Risk where the the
map is divided up into like 50 different
territories
um now you can enter a territory if
you're moving into that territory with
more supports than the person that's in
there or the person that's trying to
move in there so if you're moving in and
there's somebody already there
um then if neither of you have support
it's a one versus one and you'll bounce
back another if you'll make progress if
you have a unit that's supporting that
move into the territory then it's a two
versus one and you'll kick them out and
they'll have to retreat somewhere what
does support mean support is like it's
it's an action that you can issue in the
game so you can say this unit you write
down this unit is supporting this other
unit into this territory are these units
from opposing forces they could be they
could be and this is this is where the
interesting aspect of the game comes in
because you can support your own units
into territory but you can also support
other people's units into territories
and so that's what the negotiations
really revolve around but you don't have
to do the thing you say you're going to
do and this yeah and so you can say I'm
going to support you but then backstab
the person yeah that's absolutely right
and that tension is core to the game the
attention is absolutely core to the game
the the fact that you can make all sorts
of promises but you have to reason about
the fact that like hey they might not
trust you if you say you're going to do
something or they might be lying to you
when they say they're going to support
you
so maybe just just to jump back what's
what's the history of the game in
general is it true that Henry Kissinger
loved the game and JFK and all those
I've heard like a bunch of different
people that or is that just one of those
things that the cool kids say they do
but they don't actually play so the game
was created in the 50s yeah
um and from what I understand it was um
JFK's it was played in like the JFK
White House Henry Kissinger's favorite
game I don't know if it's true but um
that's definitely what I've heard it's
interesting that they went with World
War One
when it was created after World War II
so the story that I've heard for the
creation of the game is it was created
by
um somebody that had looked at the
history of the 20th century and they saw
World War one as a failure of diplomacy
so sure you know they saw the fact that
this war broke out as like the the
diplomats of all these countries like
really failed to prevent a war and he
wanted to create a game that would
basically teach people about diplomacy
um and it's really fascinating that like
in his ideal version of the game of
diplomacy nobody actually wins the game
because the whole point is that if
somebody is about to win then the other
players should be able to work together
to stop that person from winning and so
the ideal version of the game is just
one where nobody actually wins and you
know it kind of has a nice like
wholesome take-home message then that
you know war war is ultimately futile
and uh
and that optimal
that feudal optimal could be achieved
through great diplomacy yeah so uh is
there some asymmetry in in terms of
which is more powerful Russia versus
Germany versus
France and so on so I think the general
consensus is that France is the
strongest power in the game but the
beautiful thing about diplomacy is that
it's it's self-balancing right so it's
the fact that France has an inherent
Advantage from the beginning means that
the other players are less likely to
work with it I saw that Russia has four
units or four of something that the
others have three of something that's
true yeah so Russia starts off with four
units while all the other players start
with three but Russia is also in a much
more vulnerable position because they
have to like
um they have a lot more neighbors as
well got it larger territory more uh
yeah right more border to defend okay uh
what else is what else is important to
know about the rules so there how many
rounds are there like is this iterative
game is there is it is it finite you
just keep going indefinitely usually the
game lasts uh I would say about
15 or 20 turns
um there's in theory No Limit it could
last longer but at some point I mean if
you're playing a house game with friends
at some point you just get tired and you
all agree like okay we're gonna end the
game here and call it a draw
um if you're playing online there's
usually like set limits on when the game
will actually end and what's the end
what's the termination condition like
this this one country have to conquer
everything else so if somebody is able
to actually gain control of a majority
of the map then then they've won the
game and that is a solo Victory as it's
called now that pretty rarely happens
especially with strong players because
like I said the game is designed to
incentivize the other players to put a
stop to that and all work together to
stop the superpower
um usually what ends up happening is
that you know all the players agree to a
draw and then the the score the the win
is divided among the remaining players
um there's a lot of different scoring
systems the one that we used in our
research
um basically
um gives a score relative to how much
control you have of the map so the more
that you control the higher you score
what's the history of using this game as
a benchmark for AI research do people
use it yeah so people have been working
on AI for diplomacy since about the 80s
um there was some really exciting
research back then but the approach that
was taken was very different from what
we see today I mean the research in the
80s was a very rule-based approach kind
of kind of a heuristic approach it was
very in line with the kind of research
that was being done in the 80s you know
basically trying to encode human
knowledge into the strategy of the AI
sure
um and you know it's understandable I
mean the game is so incredibly different
and so so much more complicated than the
kinds of games that people were working
on like chess and go uh and poker that
it was honestly even hard to like start
getting making any progress in in
diplomacy can you just formulate what is
the problem from an AI perspective and
why is it hard why is it a challenging
game to solve so there's a lot of
aspects in diplomacy that make it a huge
challenge first of all you have the
natural language components and I think
this really is what makes it are really
the most difficult
game among like the major benchmarks the
fact that you have to it's not about
moving pieces on the board
your action space is basically all the
different sentences that you could
communicate to somebody else in this
game and um is there can we just like
Linger on that so
is part of it like the ambiguity in the
language
if it was like very strict
if you narrowed the set of possible
sentences you could do it would that
simplify the game significantly the the
real
difficulty is the breadth of things that
you can talk about
um you can have natural language and
other games and like Sellers of Catan
for example like you could have a
natural language Settlers of Catan AI
but the things that you're going to talk
about are basically like am I trading
you two sheep for a wood or three sheep
for a wood
um whereas in a game like diplomacy the
breadth of conversations that you're
going to have are like you know am I
going to support you are you going to
support me in return which units are
going to do what uh what did this other
person say promise you uh they're lying
because they told this other person that
they're going to do this instead
um if you help me out this turn then in
the future I'll do these things that
will help you out
um the the depth and breadth of these
conversations is is really complicated
and it's all being done in natural
language
um now you could approach it and we
actually consider doing this like you
you know having a simplified language to
make this complexity uh smaller But
ultimately we thought the most impactful
way of doing this research would be to
address the natural language component
head-on and just try to go for the full
game up front
just looking at sample games and what
the conversations look like greetings
England this should prove to be a fun
game since all the private press is
going to be made public at the end
at the least it will be interesting to
see if the Press changes because of that
anyway good okay so there's like uh yeah
that's just kind of like the generic
readings at the beginning of the game I
think that the meat comes a little bit
later when you're starting to talk about
like specific strategy and stuff
I agree there are a lot of advantages to
the two of us keeping in touch in our
Nations makes strong natural allies in
the middle game so that kind of stuff uh
making friends making enemies yeah or
like if you look at the next line so the
person's saying like I've heard uh bits
about a Lepanto and an octopus opening
and basically telling Austria like hey
just a heads up you know I've heard
these whispers about like what might be
going on behind your back yeah but so
there's all kinds of complexities in
that
in the in the language of that right
like to interpret what that what the
heck that means it's hard for us humans
but for yeah it's even harder because
you have to understand like at every
level the the semantics of that right I
mean there's there's a complexity and
understanding when somebody is saying
this to me what does that mean and then
there's also the complexity of like
should I be telling this person this
like I've overheard these these Whispers
should I be telling this person that
like hey you might be getting attacked
by by this other power Okay so
what how we're supposed to think about
okay so that's the natural language how
do you even begin trying to solve this
game it seems like this seems like the
touring test on steroids yeah and I mean
there's there's the natural language
aspect and then even besides the natural
language aspect you also have the The
Cooperative elements of the game and I
think this is actually
um something that I find really
interesting if you look at all the
previous game AI uh breakthroughs
they've all happened in these purely
adversarial games where you don't
actually need to understand how humans
play the game it's all just AI versus AI
right like you look at uh Checkers chess
go poker Starcraft Dota 2 like in some
of those cases they leveraged human data
but they never needed to they were
always just trying to have a scalable
algorithm that then they could throw a
lot of computational resources out a lot
of memory at and then eventually it
would converge to an approximation of a
Nash equilibrium this
perfect strategy that in the two player
zero some game guarantees that they're
going to be able to not lose to any
opponent so you can't leverage self-play
to solve this game you you can leverage
self-play but it's no longer sufficient
to beat humans so how do you integrate
the human into the loop of this so what
you have to do is incorporate human data
and to kind of give you some intuition
for why this is the case like imagine
you're playing a negotiation game like
like diplomacy
um but you're training completely from
scratch
without any human data the AI is not
going to suddenly like figure out how to
communicate in English it's going to
figure out some weird robot language
that only it will understand yeah and
then when you stick that in a game with
six other humans they're gonna think
this person's talking gibberish and
they're just going to Ally with each
other and team up against the bot
or not even team up against the ball but
just not work with the bot and so in
order to be able to play this game with
humans it has to understand the human
way of playing the game not this machine
way of playing the game yeah yeah that's
fascinating so right the the there's a
nuanced thing to understand because the
a chess playing program doesn't need to
play like a human to beat a human
exactly but here you have to play like a
human in order to beat them or at least
you have to understand how humans play
the game so that you can understand how
to work with them if they have certain
expectations about what does it mean to
be a good Ally what does it mean to have
like a reciprocal relationship where
we're working together you have to abide
by those conventions and if you don't
they're just going to work with somebody
else instead do you think of this as a
clean in some deep sense of the spirit
of the touring test is formulated by
Alan Turing is is it in some sense this
is what the Turing test actually looks
like
so because of open-ended natural
language conversation seems like
very difficult to evaluate like here at
a high stakes where humans are trying to
win a game that seems like how you
actually
perform the Turing test I think it's
different from the touring test like the
way that the touring test is formulated
it's about trying to distinguish a human
from a machine and seeing Oh could the
machine uh successfully pass as a human
in this adversarial setting where the
eight where the player is trying to
figure out whether it's a machine or a
human whereas in diplomacy it's not
about trying to figure out whether this
player is a human or a machine it's
ultimately about whether I can work with
this player regardless of whether they
are a human or machine and can the
machine do that better than a human can
yeah I'm going to think about that but
that just feels like
the implied requirement for that is for
the machine to be human-like
I think that's I think that's true that
if you're going to play in this human
game
you have to somehow adapt to the to the
human surroundings and the human
playstyle and to win you have to adapt
so you can't if you're the outsider
if you're not human-like I feel like
that's a losing strategy I think that's
I think that's correct yeah yeah so okay
uh
what what are the complexities here what
was your approach to it before I get to
that one thing I should explain like why
we decided to work on diplomacy so
basically what happened is in 2019
um I was wrapping up the work on six
player poker on pluribus and was trying
to think about what to work on next and
I had been seeing like all these other
breakthroughs happening in AI I mean
like 2019 you have Starcraft you have
Alpha star beating humans and Starcraft
you've got the Dota 2 stuff happening at
open AI you have GPT 2 or GPD 3 coming I
think it was gpd2 at the time and it
became clear that AI was progressing
really really rapidly
and people were throwing out these like
other games about you know what should
be the next challenge for for
multi-agent AI and I just felt like we
had to aim bigger
um
if you look at a game like chess or a
game like go they took decades for
researchers to to ultimately reach
superhuman performance at I mean like
chess took 40 Years of AI research go
took another 20 years
um
and
we we thought that diplomacy would be
this incredibly difficult challenge that
could easily take a decade to make an AI
that could play competently
um but we felt like that was that was a
goal worth aiming for
um
and so honestly I was kind of reluctant
to work on it at first because I thought
it was like too far out of the realm of
possibility but you know I was talking
to a co-worker of mine Adam Lear and he
was basically saying like yeah why not
aim for it you know we'll learn some
interesting things along the way and
maybe it'll be possible
um and so so we decided to go for it and
I think I think it was the right choice
considering just how much progress there
there was in Ai and that that progress
has continued in the years since so
winning in diplomacy what does that
really look like it means talking to six
other players six other entities agents
and convincing
and convincing them of stuff that you
want them to be convinced of like what
what exactly I'm trying to get like to
deeply understand what the problem is
ultimately
the problem is it's simple to to
quantify right like you're going to play
this game with humans and you want your
score on average to be
um as high as possible you know if you
can say like I am winning more than any
any human alive
um then you're a champion diplomacy
player
um now ultimately we haven't we didn't
reach that we got to human level
performance we actually so we played
about 40 games with with real humans
online uh the bot came in second out of
all players that played five or more
games and um so not like number one but
way way higher than well what was the
expertise level are the beginners are
they intermediate players Advanced
players so no sense that's a great
question and so I think
this kind of goes into how do you
measure the performance in diplomacy and
I would argue that when you're measuring
performance in a game like this you
don't actually want to measure it in
games with all expert players uh it's
kind of like if you're developing a
self-driving car you don't want to
measure that car on the road with a
bunch of expert stunt drivers you want
to put it on a road of like an actual
American city and see is this car
crashing less often than an expert
driver would
so so that's the metric that we've used
we we're saying like we're going to
stick this game we're gonna stick this
bot in games with a wide variety of
skill levels and then are we doing
better than a strong or expert human
player would in the same situation
that's quite brilliant because I played
a lot of sports in my life like as a
tennis Judo whatever
and it's it's somehow almost easier to
go against experts almost always I don't
I think they're more predictable in the
quality of play the the space of
strategies you're operating under is
narrower against experts it's more fun
it's really frustrating to go against
beginners also because beginners talk
trash to you when they somehow do beat
you so that's a human thing that AI
doesn't have to be worry about that but
yeah the variants and strategies right
is greater especially with natural
language it's just all over the place
then true yeah and honestly when you
look at what makes a good human
diplomacy player
um obviously they're able to handle
themselves in games with other expert
humans but where they really shine is
when they're playing with these weak
players and they know how to take
advantage of the fact that they're a
weak player that they won't be able to
like pull off a stab as well or that
they have certain Tendencies and they
can take them under their wing and
persuade them to do things that might
not even be in their interest
um the really good diplomacy players are
able to to take advantage of the fact
that there is that there are some weak
players in the game okay so if you have
to incorporate human play data how do
you do that how do you do that in order
to train an AI system to play diplomacy
yeah so that's that's really the Crux of
the problem how do we
um leverage the benefits of self-play
that have been so successful in all
these other previous games while keeping
the strategy as uh as human compatible
as possible
and so what we did is we first trained a
language model
um and then we made that language model
controllable on a set of in a set of
intents what we call intense which are
basically like an action that we want to
play and an action that we would like
the other player to play and so this
gives us a way to generate dialogue
that's not just trying to imitate the
human style
um whatever a human would say in the
situation but to actually give it a a an
intent of purpose in its communication
we can talk about a specific move or we
can make a specific request and the
determination of what that move is that
we're discussing comes from
um strategic strategic reasoning model
that uses reinforcement learning and
planning so the Computing the intents
for all the players
how's that done just so as a starting
point is that with reinforcement
learning or is that just optimal
determining what the optimal is for
intents It's a combination of
reinforcement learning and planning
um actually very similar to how you
approach how we approached poker and how
people approached like chess and go as
well we're using self-play and and
search to try to figure out what are
what is an optimal move for us and what
is a desirable move that we would like
this other player to play now the the
difference between the way that we
approached reinforcement learning and
search in this game versus those
previous games is that we have to keep
it human compatible we have to
understand how the other person is
likely to play rather than just assuming
that they're going to play like a
machine and how language gets them to
play
um in a way that maximize the chance of
following the intent you want them to
follow okay how do you do that how do
you how do you connect language to
intent so the way that RL and and
planning is done is actually not using
language so we're coming up with this
like plan for the action uh that we're
gonna play and the other person's gonna
play and then we feed that action into
the dialogue model that will then send a
message according to those plans so the
language model there is mapping
action to to message to message
one word at a time
uh basically one message at a time so
we'll we'll feed into the dialogue model
like here are the actions that you
should be discussing here's the message
here's like the the
content of the message that we would
like you to send and then it will
actually generate a message that
corresponds to that okay does this
actually work it works surprisingly well
okay how
oh man the the number of ways it
probably goes horribly I would have
imagined it goes horribly wrong
um so how the heck is it effective at
all I mean there are a lot of ways that
this could fail so for example I mean
you could have a situation where you're
you're basically like
we don't tell the the language model
like here are the pieces of our action
or the other person's action that you
should be communicating and so like
let's say you're about to attack
somebody you probably don't want to tell
them that you're going to attack them
but there's nothing in the language like
the language model is not very smart at
the end of the day so it doesn't really
have a way of knowing like well what
should I be talking about should I tell
this person I'm about to attack them or
not
um so we have to like develop a lot of
other techniques that that deal with
that
um like one of the things we do for
example is we try to calculate if I'm
going to send this message what would I
expect the other person to do in
response so if it's a message like hey
I'm going to attack you this turn
they're probably gonna you know attack
us or or defend against that attack and
so we have a way of recognizing like hey
sending this message is a negative
expected value action and we should not
send this message
so yes for particular kinds of messages
you have like an extra function that
does the uh estimates the value of that
message yeah so we have these kinds of
filters that like so it's a filter so
there's a there's a good and is that
filter in your network or is it rule
based that's that's a that's a neural
network so we're well it's a it's a
combination it's a neural network but
it's also using planning
um it's trying to compute like what is
the policy that the other players are
going to play Given that this message
um has been sent and then is that better
than not sending the message or not I
feel like that's how my brain works too
like there's a language model that
generates random crap and then there's
these other neural Nets they're
essentially filters at least that's when
I tweet
I'll usually my process of tweeting I'll
think of something and it's hilarious to
me and then about five seconds later the
filter Network comes in and says no no
that's not funny at all I mean there's
some something interesting to that kind
of process so you have a set of actions
that you you want you have an intent
that you want to achieve an intent that
you want your opponent to achieve then
you generate messages and then you
evaluated those messages will achieve
the the the
uh the goal you want yeah and we're
filtering for several things we're
filtering like is this a sensible
message you know so sometimes language
models will send will generate messages
that are just like totally nonsense
um and we try to filter those out we
also try to filter out messages that
that are basically lies
um so you know diplomacy has this
reputation as a game that's really about
um deception and lying but we try to
actually minimize the amount that the
bot would lie
um this was actually mostly or are you
no I'm just kidding okay
I mean like part of the reason for this
is that we actually found that lying
would make the bot perform worse in the
long run it would end up with a lower
score because once the bot lies
um people would never trust it again
and and trust is a huge aspect of the
game of diplomacy taking notes here
because I think this is applies to
to life lessons too oh I think it's a
really yeah really strong so like lying
is a dangerous thing to do like you you
want to avoid
obvious lying yeah I mean I think when
people play diplomacy for the first time
they approach it as a game of deception
and lying and and they
ultimately if you talk to top diplomacy
players what they'll tell you is that
diplomacy is a game about trust and
being able to build trust in an
environment that encourages people to
not trust anyone
so so that's the ultimate tension in
diplomacy how can this AI reason about
whether you are being honest in your
communication and how can the AI
persuade you that it is being honest
when it is telling you that hey I'm
actually going to support you this turn
is there some sense I don't know if you
step back and think that this process
well
indirectly help us study human
psychology
so like if trust is the ultimate goal
wouldn't that help us understand what
are the fundamental aspects of forming
trust between humans and between humans
and AI I mean that's a really really
important question that's much bigger
than the strategy games it's how can
that that's fundamental to the human
robot interaction problem how do we form
Trust
between intelligent entities
so one of the things I'm really excited
about with diplomacy
um there's never really been a good
domain to investigate these kinds of
questions yeah
um and diplomacy gives us a domain where
trust is really at the center of it
um and it's not just like you've hired a
bunch of mechanical turkers that you
know are being paid and trying to get
through the task as quickly as possible
you have these people that are really
invested in the outcome of the game and
they're really trying to do the best
that they can
um and so I'm really excited that we're
able to we actually like have put
together this we're open sourcing all of
our models we're open sourcing uh all of
the all the code and we're making the
data that we've used available to
researchers
um so that they can investigate these
kinds of questions so the data of the
different the human and the AI play of
diplomacy and the models that you use
for the generation of the messages and
the filtering yeah not not just even the
data of the AI playing with the humans
but all the training data that we that
we had that we used to train the AI to
understand how humans play the game
we're setting up a system where
researchers will be able to apply
um to be able to gain access to that
data and be be able to to use it in
their own research we should say what is
the name of the system
we're calling the bot Cicero Cicero and
what's the name like you're open
sourcing what's the name of the
repository and and the like the the
project is it also just called Cicero
the big project or are you still coming
up with the name the the data set comes
from this website web diplomacy.net is
this site that's been online for like 20
years now and uh it's one of the main
sites that people use to play diplomacy
on it we've got like 50 000 games of
diplomacy with you know natural language
communication
um over 10 million messages so it's a
pretty massive data set that people can
use to um we're hoping that the the
academic Community the research
Community is able to use it for for all
sorts of interesting research questions
so do you from having studied this game
is this
a sufficiently rich problem space to
explore this kind of human AI
interaction yeah absolutely and I think
it's
I think it's maybe the best data set
that I can think of out there to to
investigate these kinds of questions of
um negotiation trust
um persuasion I wouldn't say it's the
best data set in the world for
um human AI interaction that's a very
broad field but I think that it's
definitely up there is like you know if
you're really interested in language
models interacting with humans in you
know a setting where their incentives
are not fully aligned this seems like an
ideal data set for investigating that
so you have
um you have a paper with some impressive
results and just an impressive paper
they're taking this problem on
what's the most exciting thing to you in
terms of the results from the the paper
well I think there's ideas or results
yeah I think there's a few aspects of
the results and um that I think are
really exciting so first of all the fact
that we were able to achieve such strong
performance
um I was
surprised by and pleasantly surprised by
um so we played 40 games of diplomacy
with real humans and the bot placed
second out of all players that have
played five or more games so it's about
80 players total
um 19 of whom played five or more games
and the bot was ranked second out of
those players
um and the bot was was really good in
two Dimensions one being able to
establish strong connections with the
other players on the board being able to
like persuade them to work with it
um being able to coordinate with them
about like how it's going to work with
them and then also the Raw
tactical and strategic aspects of the
game you know being able to understand
what the other players are likely to do
being able to model their behavior and
respond appropriately to that the bot
also really excelled at what are some
interesting things that the bot said
by the way are you allowed to swear in
the um okay are there rules to what
you're allowed to say and not in
diplomacy you can say whatever you want
I think the site will get very angry at
you if you start like threatening
somebody and if we actually like if
you're threaten somebody you're supposed
to do it politely yeah politely you know
keep it in character
um
we actually had a researcher watching
the bot 24 7 for well whenever we play a
game we had a bot watching it to make
sure that it wouldn't go off the rails
and start like threatening somebody or
something like that I would just love it
if the boss started like mocking
mocking everybody like some weird quirky
strategies would emerge have you seen
anything interesting that you huh that's
a weird that's a
that's a behavior either of the filter
or the language model
that was weird to you that was yeah they
were definitely like things that the bot
would would do that were not in line
with like how humans would approach the
game and that in a good way the humans
actually you know we we've talked to
some expert diplomacy players about
these results and their takeaways that
well maybe humans are approaching this
the wrong way and this is actually like
the right way to play the game
um so what's required to win like what
um what does it mean to mess up or to
exploit the sub-optimal behavior of a
player like uh is there is there
optimally rational behavior and
irrational behavior that you need to
estimate that kind of stuff like what
what stands out to you like is there a
crack that you can exploit is there like
um a weakness that you can exploit in
the game that that everybody's looking
for
well I I think
you're asking kind of two questions
there so one like modeling the
irrationality and the suboptimality of
humans
um
you can't in diplomacy you can't treat
all the other players like they're
machines and if you do that you're
you're going to end up playing really
poorly and so we actually ran this
experiment so we we trained a bot in a
two-player zero-sum version of diplomacy
um the same way that you might approach
a game like chess or poker and the bot
was superhuman it would crush any
competitor and then we took that same
training approach and we trained a bot
for the full Seven Player version of the
game through self-play without any human
data and we stuck it in a game with six
humans and it got destroyed even in the
version of the game where there's no
explicit natural language communication
it still got destroyed because it just
wouldn't be able to understand how the
other players were approaching the game
and be able to to work with that
can you just Linger on that meeting like
there's an individual there's an
individual personality each player and
then you're supposed to remember that
but Woody means it's not able to
understand the the players well it would
for example expect the human to support
it in a certain way when the human men
would simply like think like no I'm not
supposed to support you here
um it's kind of like you know if you
develop a self-driving car and it's
trained completely from scratch with
other self-driving cars it might learn
to drive on the left side of the road
that's a totally reasonable thing to do
if you're with these other self-driving
cars that are also driving on the left
side of the road but if you put it in an
American city it's gonna crash but I
guess the intuition I'm trying to build
up is why does it then crush a human
play on heads up
this is multiple this is an aspect of
two player zero song versus games that
involve cooperation so in a two-player
zero-sum game
um you can do self-play from scratch and
you will arrive at the Nash equilibrium
where you don't have to worry about the
other player
playing in a very human sub-optimal
style that's just going to be that the
only way that deviating from an ash
equilibrium
would would change things is if it
helped you so I what's the dynamic of
cooperation that's effective in
diplomacy
do you always have to to have one friend
in the game you always want to maximize
your friends and minimize your enemies
got it and
boy in the the lying comes into play
there
so the more friends you have the better
yeah I mean I guess you have to attack
somebody or else you're not going to
make progress all right so that's the
tension but man this is too real this is
too real to this is too too close to
geopolitics of actual military conflict
in the world okay
uh that's fascinating so that
cooperation element is what makes the
game really really hard yeah and to give
you an example of of how this
sub-optimality and irrationality comes
into play there's a really common
situation in a game of diplomacy
um that where one player starts to win
and they're like at the point where
they're controlling about half the map
yeah um and the remaining players who
have all been fighting each other the
whole game all have to like work
together now to stop this other player
from winning or else everybody's gonna
lose
um and it's kind of like you know Game
of Thrones like I don't know if you've
seen the show like you know you got the
the others coming from the north and
like all the people have to start work
out their differences and stop them from
from taking over
um
and the bot will do this like the bot
will work with the other players to stop
the superpower from winning but if it
doesn't really if it's trained from
scratch or it doesn't really have a good
grounding in how humans approach it it
will also at the same time attack the
other players with its extra units so
all the units that are not necessary to
stop the superpower from winning it will
use those to grab as many centers as
possible from the other players and
in totally rational play the other
players should just live with that you
know they have to understand like hey a
score of one is better than a score of
zero so
um so okay he's grabbed my centers but I
I'll just deal with it
but humans don't act that way right the
human gets really angry at the bot and
ends up throwing the game because you
know I'm gonna screw you over because
you did something that's not fair to me
got it and are you supposed to model
that is the boss supposed to model that
kind of human frustration yeah exactly
and so that is something that seems
almost impossible to model purely from
scratch without any human data it's a
very cultural thing yeah um and so you
need
human data to be able to understand that
hey that's how humans behave and you
have to work around that it might be
suboptimal it might be rational but but
that's an aspect of humanity that you
have to have you have to deal with so
how difficult is it to train on human
data given that human data is very
limited versus what the US a purely
self-play mechanism can generate that's
actually one of the major challenges
that we faced in the research that we
had a good amount of human data we had
about 50 000 games what we try to do is
leverage as much soft play as possible
while still leveraging the human data so
what we do is we do self-play very
similar to how it's been done in poker
and go but we try to regularize the
self-play towards the human data
basically the way to think about it is
um we penalize the bot for choosing
actions that are very unlikely under how
under the human data set
and how do you know is there is this
some kind of function that says this is
human-like enough yeah so we we train a
bot through supervised learning to model
the human play as much as possible so we
basically like train a neural net
um on those 50 000 games and that gives
us an approximate that gives us a policy
that resembles to some extent how humans
actually play the game now this isn't a
perfect model of human play because we
don't have unlimited data we don't have
unlimited neural net capacity
um but it gives us some approximation uh
is there some data on the internet
that's useful besides just diplomacy so
on the language side of things is there
some can you go to like Reddit
and
um so sort of background model
formulation that that's useful for the
game of diplomacy yeah absolutely and so
for the language model which
um it's kind of like a separate question
you know we didn't use the language
model during self-play training but we
pre-trained the language model on you
know tons of internet data as much as
possible and then we fine-tuned it
specifically on the diplomacy games so
we are able to like Leverage The Wider
data set in order to fill in
some of the gaps in like how
communication happens more broadly
besides just like specifically in these
diplomacy games Okay cool so what what's
some what are some interesting things
that came to life from this from this
work uh to you like what are some
insights
about
um
about games where natural language is
involved and cooperation deep
cooperation is involved well I think
there's a few insights um so first of
all
the fact that you can't rely purely or
even largely on self-play that you
really have to have an understanding of
how humans approach the game
um I think that that's one of the major
conclusions that I'm drawing from this
work
um and that is I think applicable more
broadly to a lot of different games so
we've actually already taken the
approaches that we've used in diplomacy
and tried them on uh Cooperative card
game called Hanabi and we've had a lot
of success in that game as well
um on the language side
I think the fact that we were able to
control the language model through this
intense approach was very effective
um and it allowed us instead of just
imitating how humans would communicate
were able to go beyond that and able to
feed into it superhuman strategies that
it can then um you know generate
messages corresponding to
is there something you could say about
detecting whether a person or AI is
lying or not
the bot doesn't explicitly try to
calculate whether somebody is lying or
not but what it will do is try to
predict what actions they're going to
take given the communications given the
messages that they've sent to us so
given our conversation what do I think
you're going to do and implicitly there
is a calculation about whether you're
lying to me in that
you know if if you're based on your
messages if I think you're going to
attack me this turn
um even though your messages say that
you're not then you know essentially the
bot is predicting that you're lying but
it doesn't view it as as lying the same
way that we would view it as lying
but you could probably reformulate with
all the same data and make a classifier
lying or not yeah I think I think you
could do that um that was not something
that we were focused on but I think that
it is possible that you know if you came
up with some measurements of like what
does it mean to tell a lie because
there's there's a spectrum right like if
you're withholding some information is
that a lie
um if you're mostly telling the truth
but you forgot to mention this like one
action out of like 10 is that a lie
um it's hard to draw the line but you
know if you're willing to do that and
then you could possibly use it to uh
dude this feels like an argument inside
a relationship now what constitutes a
lie
um depends what you mean by the
definition of the word is okay
um
still it's fascinating because trust and
lying is all intermixed into this and
it's language models that are becoming
more and more sophisticated it's just a
fascinating space to explore
um
what do you see as the future of this
work
um that is inspired by the Breakthrough
performance that you're getting here
with diplomacy
uh
I think there's a few different
directions to take this work
um
I I think really what it's showing us is
the potential that language models have
I mean I think a lot of people didn't
think that this kind of result was
possible even today despite all the
progress that's been made in language
models and so it shows us how we can
Leverage The Power of things like
self-play on top of language models to
get
um increasingly better performance and
the ceiling is really
much higher than what we have right now
is this transferable somehow to
to chat Bots
for the more General task of dialogue
so because there is a kind of
negotiation here a dance between
entities that are trying to cooperate
and at the same time a little bit
adversarial which I think Maps somewhat
to the general
you know the entire process of Reddit or
like internet communication you're
cooperating you're adversarial you're
having debates you're having uh
camaraderie all that kind of stuff
I think one of the things that's really
useful about diplomacy is that we have a
well-defined value function there is a
well-defined score that the bot is
trying to optimize and and in a in a
setting like a general chatbot setting
it needs it would need that kind of
um objective in order to fully leverage
the techniques that we've developed
what about like what we talked about
earlier with NPCs inside video games
like how can it be used to create
for Elder Scrolls 6 more compelling um
NPCs
that you could talk to instead of
instead of committing all kinds of
violence with a sword and fighting
dragons just sitting in a Tavern and
drink all day and talk to the chatbot
the way that we've approached AI
diplomacy is you condition the language
on an intent now that intent and
diplomacy is an is an action but it
doesn't have to be and you can imagine
you know you could have NPCs in video
games or the metaverse or whatever where
there's some intent or there's some
objective that they're trying to
maximize and you can specify what that
is
um and and then the language can
correspond to that intent now I'm not
saying that this is you know happening
imminently but um I'm saying that this
is like a future application potentially
of this direction of research so what's
the more General formulation of this
making self-play be able to scale the
way self-play does and still maintain
human-like Behavior
the way that we've approached self-play
in diplomacy is like
we're we're trying to
come up with good intents to condition
the language model on and the space of
intents is actions that can be played in
the game now there is like the potential
to have a broader set of intents things
like you know long-term cooperation or
long-term uh objectives or you know
gossip about what another player was
saying
um these are things that we're currently
not conditioning the language model on
and so it's not able to we're not able
to control it to say like oh you should
be talking about this thing right now
but it's quite possible that you could
expand the scope of intents to be able
to allow it to talk about those things
now in the process of doing that the
self-play would become much more
complicated
um and so that is a potential for for
future work okay the increasing the
number of intents I still am not quite
clear
how you keep the self-play
integrated into the human world yeah I'm
a little bit loose on the uh uh on
understanding how you do that so we
train a neural Nets to
um imitate the human data as closely as
possible and that's what we call the
anchor policy and now when we're doing
self-play
the the problem with the anchor policy
is that it's not a perfect approximation
of how humans actually play because we
don't have infinite data because we
don't have unlimited neural network
capacity it's actually a relatively
sub-optimal approximation of how humans
actually play and we can improve that
approximation by adding planning and RL
and so what we do is we get a better
approximation a better model of human
play by
during the self-play process we say you
can deviate from this human anchor
policy if there is an action that has
you know particularly High expected
value
um but it would have to be a really high
expected value in order to to deviate
from from this human-like policy so you
basically say try to maximize your
expected value while at the same time
stay as close as possible to the human
policy and there is a parameter that
controls those the the relative
weighting of those Computing objectives
so the question I have
is how sophisticated can the anchor
policy get
to have a policy that approximates human
behavior right yeah so as you increase
the number of intents as you generalize
the the space in which this is
applicable
and given that the human data is limited
try to anticipate a policy that works
for in a much larger number of cases
like how how difficult is the process of
forming a damn good anchor policy
well it really comes down to how much
human data you have so it's all boss
scale in the human data I think the more
human data you have the better and I
think that that's going to be the major
bottleneck in in scaling to to more
complicated
um domains but that said
you know there might be the potential
just like in the language model where we
leveraged you know tons of data on the
internet and then specialized it for
diplomacy
um there is the future potential that
you can leverage huge amounts of data
across the board and then specialize it
in the data set that you have for
diplomacy and in that way you're
essentially augmenting the amount of
data that you have
to what degree does this apply
to the general the real world diplomacy
the geopolitics
you know there's a game theory has a
history of being applied to understand
and to give us hope about nuclear
weapons for example the mutually assured
destruction is a game theoretic concept
that you can formulate some people say
it's oversimplified but nevertheless
here we are and we somehow haven't blown
ourselves up do you see a future where
this kind of
this kind of system can be used to help
us make decisions geopolitical decisions
in the world
well like I said the original motivation
for the game of diplomacy was the
failures of World War One The Diplomatic
failures that led to War uh and the real
take-home message of diplomacy is that
you know if people approach diplomacy
the right way then war is ultimately
unsuccessful
um the way that I see at war is an
inherently negative sum game right
there's always a better outcome than War
for all the parties involved and my hope
is that you know as AI progresses then
maybe this technology could be used to
help people make better decisions
um across the board and you know
hopefully avoid negative some outcomes
like War
yeah I mean I just came back from
Ukraine I'm going back there on deep
personal levels
think a lot about
how peace can be achieved and I'm a big
believer in conversation or leaders
getting together and having
conversations and trying to understand
each other
yeah it's fascinating to think um
whether each one of those leaders can
run a simulation ahead of time like if
I'm an [ __ ]
what are the possible consequences if
I'm nice what are the possible
consequences
um my guess
is that if the president of the United
States got together with uh
Vladimir zielinski and Vladimir Putin
that there will be significant benefits
to
um the president United States not
having an ego
of kind of
playing down of giving away a lot of
chips for the future successful world so
giving a lot of power to the two
presidents of the competing Nations to
achieve peace that's my guess but it'd
be nice to run a bunch of simulations
but then you have to have human data
right you really because it's like the
game of diplomacy is fundamentally
different than geopolitics you need data
you need like I guess that's the
question I have like how transferable is
this to uh like I don't know any kind of
negotiation right like to any kind of
look some local I don't know a bunch of
lawyers like arguing like at a divorce
like divorce lawyers like how
transferable this all kinds of human
negotiation well I feel like this isn't
a question that's unique to diplomacy I
mean I think you look at RL
breakthroughs reinforcement learning
breakthroughs in previous games as well
like you know AI for Starcraft AI for
Atari you haven't really seen it
deployed in the real world because you
have these problems of it's really hard
to collect a lot of data
um and you don't have a you don't have a
well-defined action space you don't have
a well-defined reward function these are
all things that you really need for
reinforcement learning and planning to
be really successful today now there are
some domains where you do have that
um code generation is one example
theorem proving mathematics that's
another example where you have a
well-defined action space you have a
well-defined reward function and those
are the kinds of domains where I can see
RL in the short term being incredibly
powerful but
yeah I think that those are the barriers
to deploying this at scale in the real
world but and the hope is that in the
long run we'll be able to get there yeah
but you see diplomacy feels like closer
to the real world than does Starcraft
like because it's natural language right
you're operating in a space of intense
and in a space of natural language that
feels very close to the real world and
it also feels like you could get data on
that from the internet
yeah and that's why I do think that
diplomacy is taking a big step closer to
the real world than anything that's came
before in terms of game AI breakthroughs
the fact that
you know we're we're communicating in
natural language we've we're leveraging
the fact that we have this like General
data set of uh dialogue and
communication from a breadth of the
internet
um that is that is a big step in that
direction we're not 100 there but um but
we're getting closer at least
so if we actually return back to Poker
and chess are some of the ideas that
you're learning here with diplomacy
could you construct AI systems that play
like humans
like um make for a fun opponent
in a game with Jess yeah absolutely
we've already started looking into this
direction a bit so we tried to use the
techniques that we've developed for
diplomacy uh to make chess and go AIS
and what we found is that it led to much
more human-like strong chess and go
players the way that
AIS like stockfish today play is in a
very inhuman style it's very strong but
it's very different from how humans play
and so we can take the techniques that
we've developed for diplomacy we do
something similar in um in chess and go
and we end up with the bot that's both
strong and human-like
um to elaborate on this a bit like one
way to approach making a human-like AI
for chess is to collect a bunch of human
games like a bunch of human Grand Master
games and just do supervised learning on
those games but the problem is that if
you do that what you end up with is an
AI That's substantially weaker than the
human Grand Masters that you've trained
on because the neural net is not able to
approximate the the Nuance of the
strategy this goes back to the planning
thing that I mentioned the search thing
that I talked about before that these
human Grand Masters when they're playing
they're using search and they're using
planning and the neural net alone unless
you have a massive neural net that's
like a thousand times bigger than what
we have right now it's not able to
approximate those details very
effectively
and on the other hand you can leverage
search and planning very heavily but
then what you end up with is an AI that
plays in a very different style from how
humans play the game
now if you strike this intermediate
balance by setting the um the
regularization parameters correctly and
say you can do planning but try to keep
it close to the human policy then you
end up with an AI that plays in both a
very human-like style and a very strong
style and you can actually even tune it
to have a certain ELO rating so you can
say play in the style of like a 2800
elohuman
um I wonder if you could do specific
type of humans or categories of humans
so not just skill but Style
yeah I think so and so this is this is
where the the research gets interesting
like you know one of the things that I
was thinking about is and this is
actually already being done I think
there's a researcher at the University
of Toronto that's working on this
um is to make an ad that plays in the
style of a particular player like Magnus
Carlson for example you can make an AI
that plays like Magnus Carlson and then
where I think this gets interesting is
like maybe you're up against Magnus
Carlson in the world championship or
something you can play against this
Magnus Carlson bot to prepare against
the real Magnus Carlson and you can try
to explore strategies that he might
struggle with
um and try to figure out like how do you
beat this player in particular
um on the other hand you can also have
Magnus Carlson working with this bot to
try to figure out where he's weak um and
where he needs to improve his strategy
um and so I can Envision this future
where data on specific chess and go
players becomes extremely valuable
because you can use that data to create
specific models of how these particular
players play so increasingly human-like
behavior and Bots however
as you've mentioned makes cheating cheat
detection much harder it it does yeah
the way that sheet detection Works in a
game like poker and a game like chess
and go from what I understand is trying
to see like is this person making moves
that are very common among chess AIS or
you know AIS in general
um but very uncommon among top human
players
and if you have the development of these
AIS that play in a very strong style but
also a very human-like style then that
poses serious challenges for cheat
detection and it makes you now ask
yourself a hard question about what is
the role of AI systems as they become
more and more integrated in our society
and this kind of human AI
um
integration has has some deep ethical
issues that we should be aware of and
also it's a kind of cyber security
challenge right for to make you know one
of the assumptions we have when we play
games is that there's a trust that is
only humans involved and there
the better AI systems to create which
makes it super exciting human-like AI
systems with different styles of humans
is really exciting but then we have to
have the defenses better and better and
better if we're to trust that we uh can
enjoy human versus human game in a
deeply Fair way it's fascinating so it's
just uh it's humbling yeah I think there
is a lot of like negative potential for
this kind of Technology but you know at
the same time there's a lot of upside
for it as well so you know for example
right now it's really hard to learn how
to get better in games like chess and
poker and go because the way that the AI
plays is so foreign and incomprehensible
but if you have these AIS that are
playing you know you can say like Oh I'm
a 2000 ELO human how do I get to 2200
now you can have an AI that plays in the
style of a 2200 elohiman and that will
help you get better or you know you
mentioned this problem of like how do
you know that you're actually playing
with humans when you're playing like
online in video games well now we have
the potential of populating these like
Virtual Worlds with
um agents like AI agents that are
actually fun to play with and you don't
have to always be playing with other
humans to to you know have a fun time
so yeah a lot a lot of upside potential
too and I think you know with any sort
of tool there's there's the potential
for a lot of greatness and a lot of uh
downsides as well so in the paper they
got a chance to look at there's a
section on uh ethical considerations
what's in that section what are some
ethical considerations here is it some
of the stuff we've already talked about
there's some things that we've already
talked about
um I think
specific to diplomacy you know there's
there's also the the challenge that the
game is
you know there is a deception aspect to
the game
um and so
you know have developing language models
that are capable of deception is I think
a dicey issue and something that you
know makes research on diplomacy
particularly challenging
um and
you know so so those kinds of issues of
like should we even be developing AIS
that are capable of lying to people
that's something that we have to you
know think carefully about uh that's so
cool I mean that you have to do that
kind of stuff in order to figure out
where the ethical lines are but I can
see in the future it being illegal to
have a consumer product that
lies
yeah yeah like your personal assistant
AI system is not a lot is always have to
tell the truth but if if I ask it do I
do I look did I get fatter over the past
month I sure as hell want that AI system
to lie to me uh so there's a trade-off
between lying and being and being nice
after somehow find
where's the ethics in that and we're
back to discussions inside relationships
anyway what were you saying oh yeah I
was getting like yeah this yeah that's
kind of going to the question of like
what what is a lot you know is a white
lie a bad lie is it an ethical lie yeah
you know those kinds of questions uh boy
we return time and time again to deep
human questions as we design AI systems
that's exactly what they do they put a
mirror to humanity to help us understand
ourselves
there's there's also the issue of like
you know in these diplomacy experiments
in order to do
a fair comparison you know what we found
is that there's an inherent anti-ai bias
in these kinds of games so we actually
played a tournament in a non-language
version of the game where you know we we
told the participants like hey in every
single game there's going to be an AI
and what we found is that the humans
would spend basically the entire game
like trying to figure out who the bot
was and then as soon as they thought
they figured it out they would all team
up and try to kill it
um and you know overcoming that inherent
anti-ai bias is is a challenge um on the
flip side
I think when robots become the enemy
that's when we get to heal our human
divisions and then we can become one as
long as we have one enemy it's it's that
Reagan thing when aliens show up that's
when we we put our side our divisions
we've become one one human species right
you might have our differences but we're
at least all human at least we all hate
the robots no no no I think there will
be actually in the future something like
a civil rights movement for robots I
think that's the fascinating things
about AI systems and is they ask they
force us to ask about
ethical questions about what is
sentience what is uh how do we feel
about systems that are capable of
suffering or capable of displaying
suffering and how do we design products
that show emotion and not how do we feel
about that lying is another topic are we
going to allow Bots to lie and not and
where's the balance between being nice
and and telling the truth I mean these
are all fascinating human questions it's
like so exciting to be in the century
when we create systems that
take these philosophical questions that
have been asked for centuries and now we
can engineer them inside systems where
like you really have to answer them
because you'll have
transformational impact on human society
depending on what you design inside
those systems it's fascinating and like
you said I feel like diplomacy is a step
towards the direction of the real world
applying these RL methods towards the
real world
from from all the Breakthrough
performances and go and chess and
Starcraft and DOTA this is this feels
like the real world especially now my
mind's been on war in military conflict
this feels like it can give us some deep
insights about human behavior at the
large geopolitical scale
um
what do you think
is the um breakthrough
or
the directions of work that will take us
towards solving intelligence towards
creating AGI systems you've been a part
of creating
um by the way we should say a part of
great teams that do this of creating
systems that achieve breakthrough
performances on before thought
unsolvable problems like poker uh
multiplayer poker diplomacy
we're taking steps towards that
direction what do you think it takes to
go all the way to create superhuman
level intelligence
you know there's a lot of people trying
to figure that out right now
um and you know I should say like the
amount of progress that's been made
especially in the past few years is
truly phenomenal I mean you look at
where AI was 10 years ago and the idea
that you could have AIS that can
generate language and generate images
the way they're doing today and able to
play a game like diplomacy was just like
Unthinkable
um even even five years ago let alone
ten years ago
um
now there are there are aspects of AI
that I think are still lacking um
I think there's General agreements that
one of the major issues with AI today is
that it's very data inefficient it's
very it requires a huge number of
samples of training examples to be able
to train you know you look at an AI that
plays go and it needs millions of games
of go to uh to learn how to play the
game well whereas a human can pick it up
in like you know I don't know how many
games does a human go player go go Grand
Master play in their lifetime probably
you know in the thousands or tens of
thousands I guess
um
so that's that's one issue overcome
efficiency overcoming this challenge of
data efficiency and this is particularly
important if we want to deploy AI
systems in real world settings
um where they're interacting with humans
because you know for example with
robotics it's really hard to generate a
huge number of samples it's it's a
different story when you're working in
these you know totally virtual games
where you can play a million games and
it's no big deal I was planning on just
launching like a thousand of these
robots in Austin I don't think it's
illegal for Lego robots to roam the
streets and just collect data that's not
of course the worst that could happen
yeah I kind of I mean that's one way to
overcome the data efficiency problem is
like scale it yeah like I actually tried
to see if there's a law against robots
like Lego robots just operating
in in this in the streets of a major
city and there isn't I couldn't find any
so
um I'll take it all the way to the
Supreme Court
robot rights okay anyway sorry you were
saying so the so what what are the ideas
for getting becoming more data efficient
uh I mean that's that's the trillion
dollar question in AI today I mean if
you can figure out how to make AI
systems more more data efficient then
that's
a huge breakthrough so nobody really
knows right now it could be just a
gigantic background model language model
and then you do
um the training becomes like prompting
that model
to uh
to essentially do a kind of querying a
search into the space of the things it's
learned to customize that to whatever
problem you're trying to solve so maybe
if you form a large enough language
model you can go quite quite a long way
that you know I think there's some truth
to that I mean you look at the way
humans approach
um a game like poker they're not coming
at it from scratch they're coming at it
with a huge amount of background
knowledge about you know how humans work
how the world Works
um the idea of money so they're able to
leverage that kind of information to uh
to to pick up the game faster uh so it's
not really a fair comparison to then
compare it to an AI That's like learning
from scratch and maybe one of the ways
that we address this uh sample
complexity problem is by allowing AIS to
leverage that general knowledge across a
ton of different domains
so like I said you did uh a lot of
incredible work in the space of research
and actually Building Systems what
advice would you give to uh let's start
with beginners what advice would you
give to beginners interested in machine
learning just there at the very start of
their Journey they're in high school and
college thinking like this seems like a
fascinating world what advice would you
give them
um I I would say
that there are a lot of people working
on similar aspects of machine learning
and to not be afraid to try something a
bit different my own path
in AI is pretty atypical for a machine
learning researcher today I mean I
started out working on Game Theory and
um and then shifting more towards
reinforcement learning as time went on
and that actually had a lot of benefits
I think because it allowed me to look at
these problems in a very different way
from the way a lot of machine learning
researchers view it and that comes with
um drawbacks in some respects like I
think there's definitely aspects of
machine learning where you know I'm
weaker than most of the researchers out
there but I think that diversity of
perspective
um you know when I'm working with my
teammates
um there's something that I'm bringing
to the table and there's something that
they're bringing to the table and that
kind of collaboration becomes very
fruitful for that reason so there could
be problems like like poker like you've
chosen diplomacy that could be problems
like that still out there that you can
just tackle even if it seems extremely
difficult
um I think that there's a lot of
challenges challenges left and I think
having a diversity of viewpoints and
backgrounds is really helpful for
working together to figure out how to
tackle those kinds of challenges so as a
beginner so that I would say that's
that's more for like a grad student they
already built up a base like a complete
beginner what's a good journey so for
you that was doing some more on the math
side of things doing Game Theory all
that good so it's basically build up a
foundation in something so programming
mathematics it could even be physics but
build build that Foundation
yeah I would say build a strong
foundation in math and computer science
and statistics in these kinds of areas
but but don't be afraid to try something
that's different and learn something
that's different from you know the the
thing that everybody else is doing to
get into machine learning um you know
there's there's value in having a
different background than everybody else
um yeah so but certainly having a strong
math background especially in things
like linear algebra and statistics and
probability
um are incredibly helpful today for for
learning about and understanding machine
learning do you think one day we'll be
able to since you're taking steps from
poker to diplomacy one day we'll be able
to uh
figure out how to live life optimally
well what is it like in in poker and
diplomacy you need a value function you
need to have a reward system and so what
does it mean to live a life that's
optimal so okay so then you can exactly
like lay down a reward function being
like I want to be rich or I want to be
um
I want to be in a happy relationship and
then you'll say well
do X
you know there's there's a lot of uh
talk today about in in AI safety circles
about like this specification of you
know reward functions so you you say
like okay my objective is to be rich and
maybe the AI tells you like okay well if
you want to maximize the probability
that you're rich go rob a bank sure and
so you wanna is that is that really what
you want is your objective really to be
rich at all costs or is it more nuanced
than that so the understand the
consequences yeah
yeah so yeah that that's so maybe life
is more about defining the reward
function that minimizes the unintended
consequences
than it is about the actual policy that
gets you to the rewards function maybe
life is just about constantly updating
the reward function
I think one of the challenges in life is
is figuring out exactly what that reward
function is sometimes it's pretty hard
to specify the same way that you know
trying to handcraft the optimal policy
in a game like chess is really difficult
it's not so clear-cut what the reward
function is for for life
I think one day AI will figure it out
and I wonder what that would be until
then
I just really appreciate the kind of
work you're doing and um it's it's
really fascinating taking a leap into a
more and more real world like
um problem space and just achieving
incredible results by applying
reinforcement learning no since I saw
you work on poker you've been in
constant inspiration it's an honor to
get to finally talk to you and uh this
is really fun thanks for having me
thanks for listening to this
conversation with no Brown
to support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
Sun Tzu and the Art of War
the whole secret lies in confusing the
enemy so that he cannot fathom our real
intent
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time